um basically fuses two broadcast
operations
um
so you can write rules like this and
immediately apply it on um the symbolic
expressions that you
just created
and here's an example here i'm creating
a rule uh for the matrix in multiply
optimization and then
um
here the input is x times y times b and
x times y is 10 by 10. but it's
ultimately just
two
matrix vector multiplies
so if you apply the rule here you get
back a new expression uh which
which shows that it's uh
it's first doing the matrix vector
multiply here and then doing the matrix
vector multiply on the resulting vector
so i will talk about this
this notation of array off in the next
slide um
[Music]
yeah so if you if you
enable this flag
this flag
cultural array off
from symbolics uh every time you perform
an array operation you get back uh a
notation let me check again um
which says what is the
loop going on inside basically so this
is a variation on
what many people call the einstein
summation notation
which basically means that
for every i
this is how you compute it right so it's
saying that for every i take x
i comma k
and multiply with y comma k
and since k does not appear on the left
hand side this also means that the
dimension where k is used must be
reduced over and by default we reduce
over it with the plus operation
so this becomes a matrix vector multiply
in the second example we have
j in the left hand side but not i
um
oh yeah sorry
this was supposed to be prod so here i i
i want to use a different reduce
function uh which is not plus right so
um that's also allowed yeah you can have
a star as the radius operation so in
this case it's doing a product over the
first dimension
um and that's the area of you get and
yeah finally you can nest these things
so for example this adjoint is written
as uh
one comma i equals
uh y of
y of i
uh which basically
turns a
column a column vector into a row vector
and
then
it's doing a couple of broadcasts
um
and broadcast is in this case it's just
a
um
it's all yeah in this case it's just
um
um doing two loops right um
yeah so as you can see it encodes both
the high level operation
and
this loop formulation of the operations
that we are doing and it turns out we
can represent
most of julia's
standard
library using
this notation so for example broadcast
reduce over any dimension um
some of the linear algebra up to glass
uh
or like
even blast three will accept the solve
operations can be represented in this
way
and
it also has the feature to represent
um
[Music]
indexing so slicing arrays can also be
represented using this array of notation
so when you do a get index this is what
it internally represents
uh here i have a slice of x
being
broadcasted with the sine function so
you can see the internal array of is
basically it's a identity uh operation
but
with the index set subset from the
entire indexer
um
yeah so why do we need this tensor
notation it seems like a extra level of
complication but uh it turns out it
makes a lot of things very easy
so first of all it encodes the loops
this means we can generate the loops
when we want to compile it down to julia
cloud
secondly
it also
appears to have frozen in the stream
he'll be back shortly
and we lost him completely
right he should be back
yeah so
um i
do you know where uh if you were seeing
this life
yeah i can see this like no but uh was
this the slide that was before yeah you
were you were explaining um
about you hadn't gotten to talking about
differentiation or anything okay cool
yeah so i was
i was just explaining about getting
likes i guess
um
okay yeah so i'll just continue from
here so i was uh saying that uh
even get index can be represented using
this notation and we do it in symbolics
um so in this case x there is a slice of
x here and the internal loop contains
the uh ranges of the indices
and this this also makes it easy to
have shape propagation and checking
going on at all times
um
okay so why do we need this pencil
notation it looks like an extra layer of
complication but it turns out it makes a
lot of things easier first of all we
have the loops encoded in this notation
so we can generate the loops uh in julia
when we need to compile a certain
operation
secondly shape propagation just becomes
centralized so we don't have to do it
for every single operation
that is there in the standard library so
we just do it for
arrays in general
and yeah differentiation
becomes possible we just have to
differentiate the internal
expressions and finally it also makes it
possible for us
to go back and compute a specific
element of
the result of an array operation right
so here i have a
x broadcast over x times y and i'm
indexing the first element so if you do
this in the repo you just get this lazy
expression
and then if you call
symbolics.scalarize it's going to go
back and
take the
tensor notation and start applying the
indices that you want starting from one
right and then it's going to say that
the result of the first
element here is going to be
the dot product of y with the first
row of x
and
x of that okay so
this becomes possible with the tensor
notation
um
yeah so and then we can
compile these uh
expressions to julia code uh using this
two exper there are three ways to do it
so firstly there is two expert which
will just give a code fragment we're
using the same names
um
for how to do this and then there's in
place expert which
gives a for loop
and you also need to give like an output
array symbol
and
basically it
it gives some code which fills up the
output array symbol with the operation
required so in this case it's a
um
it's a matrix vector multiply so it has
one loop
um
going over all the case
and one loop going over all the
uh eyes
and filling up each element of the
output
um
so and then finally we have this build
function
uh which is what modeling toolkit uses
so if you give it an array operation and
then say x and y are the inputs it just
gives you back
a function which takes x and y as inputs
tuple x and y as inputs and
does the operation required um
and in this case it's using like the
just the high level representation not
the
loops representation
um
yeah so i wanted to talk a little bit
about
some languages which
do
which are doing
novel things in
[Music]
array specific
um
domain-specific languages um
so
first of all there is like jax which uh
mirrors the numpy api
so it it is kind of symbolic in the
sense that when you
um
when you create arrays in jacks and
apply operations in them it maintains
this expression tree and then it can do
automatic differentiation on it
and it can do
shape propagation and checking and
the internals work mostly as if we are
doing you know
symbolic tracing as if you're running
something with symbolization right um
but it's also just geared towards
machine learning
it doesn't explicitly provide symbols
[Music]
and then there is dex which is a
functional language
it's kind of like haskell the flavor or
ml and
um yeah
and
it it allows you to express
for loops or comprehensions
and
the
index sets are part of the type so which
means that like the index ranges are
part of the type basically and every
time some operation happens the index
sets become
um
yeah index sets are
type checked
in a sense
um
but this language does not have
metaprogramming which means
you can't take the expressions
themselves and transform it in the
language
so
but if you think about it
since symbolics
can compile down to julia code
when you're doing symbolics you are
doing like programming um in some sense
and it's like the most
um
user-friendly form of meta programming
where
there's the you're manipulating these
expressions with like a rich library of
uh things around it um
yeah and there's halide which is mostly
geared towards parallelism i think i'm
running out of time so
um
uh parallelism of for loops
and
you can go um for five more minutes oh
okay thank you straight there so yeah
cool thanks
um so
yeah again halide is uh
all the features have to be built into
the language
um
but uh i think symbolic arrays let you
allow you to have much more flexibility
in that sense
um
so in summaries area symbolics have been
around for a while but like their
the
attitude towards it from other classes
other computer algae algebra systems
have been like you know this is just
another type of symbol um
but in symbolics we take it a step
further and we have multiple encodings
and in the sense we also maintain like
the for loop representation of an er
array operation which allows us to do
compilation and optimizations um
um and
um
yeah
this is super important for the same
ecosystem because that's like compiling
symbolics is what we care about the most
um
yeah and it becomes a meta programming
tool in the end um
yeah so
things we are working on in the future
uh includes loop
generating the code uh to be very
efficient uh using loop vectorization
and using crystal rod in general uh
the differentiation of array operations
is coming and we're working on stencils
and uh
i have this project to do like xla style
optimization of flux models so if
anybody here is interested in doing that
then please
talk to me after the talk
um
yeah i wanted to acknowledge
yingbo chris and alan
for helping me work on this
yingbo has
when i have questions i always talk to
the ingo and it always clears me up uh
clears them up so
uh if you want to
use symbolics i hope you can you know
this already you can go to julia
symbolics.org and read more about it
thanks
all right thank you shashi um so why not
since we said we give you five minutes
why don't we we do one question from
discord
um and then maybe you can take a look at
the other one uh that's on there um so
the first one was uh asking about your
the chain of array multiplications that
you showed yeah
saying can you apply a rule that
calculates the optimal array
multiplication order using dynamical
programming or such
that they didn't think the a simple
greedy rule uh works in general when you
have i guess a bigger chain
uh-oh it seems like shashi froze on us
um okay so maybe we should just move on
to the next talk um
since shashi is frozen anyways um
so
uh
ron john do you want to handle setting
it up great um okay
can you hear me yes i can okay can you
see my uh presentation i can see your
presentation so hopefully everyone else
can um all right so our next speaker is
uh elia elmer um who is a i believe a
graduate student at city university of
new york in computer science
um and has done a lot of really nice
work on structural identifiability
tooling and julian is going to give us
an introduction to that so please take
it away
thank you for the introduction uh my
name is ilya hi everybody um i am a
candidate at the graduate center at the
city university of new york
and today i will present a quick
tutorial on structural identifiability
solution in julia
um i uh my research topic is uh
parameter identifiability algorithms
and um
in this talk i'll first introduce the
identifiability problem
um we'll
i will present um two
julia based solutions um
one of them namely structural
infallibility dot jl is included inside
ml framework uh saml infrastructure
infrastructure
the other one a structural
identifiability analyzer is um
a julia port from maple of another
identifiability algorithm that's very
efficient so we'll kind of go we'll go
over the differences uh during the
example section we'll uh i will
do a quick live coding demo
and then we'll highlight some
differences and how one package can
complement another
during the conclusions section
so what is a structural identifiability
problem and well in general parameter
identifiability deals with
situations where
we are given an ode model and we would
like to know whether we can determine
parameters of that model and
you know one way to do it would be to
set up an experiment measure
certain variables certain state values
and then try to manipulate the data to
get the value of a parameter
a structural identifiability is a
theoretical notion that can answer that
question from a symbolic
ode system
and such structural identifiability is
uh can be categorized further into
global and local so global
identifiability is when a parameters
value can be determined uniquely and
we say a parameter is
locally identifiable or local
identifiability case is when there are
finitely many solutions
to
for the current parameter
if neither of those situations occurs
and maybe the parameter has infinitely
many values then we say that such
parameter is non-identifiable now there
are ways to mitigate this issue
i will mention them but i don't think
i'll have enough time to kind of cover
in full details
but we'll definitely talk about what can
be done for that case
so let's consider a simple uh example
uh we have a
um the following input structure and
this structure will be preserved for
either julia package either cyan or
structural identifiability so have an
ode um
of which there could be more than one
but for this example let's consider a
single one so we've got two parameters
and one state variable and we have an
output function consider this something
that can be measured during the
experimental stage
and so if we were to plug this into each
of the packages cyan structural
information analyzer would tell us that
the initial condition and the parameter
b are globally identifiable while
parameter a is only local identifiable
that does make sense i mean measure y at
0 and you get the initial condition
a is seen with a square so there will be
two values that could be that could
satisfy
an equation for a
so finding the main solutions for a and
unique solution for b and x
structural identifiability on the other
hand will tell us that b is globally and
a is local identifiable and will not
provide any information about the states
so this is the first difference since we
encounter between the two packages
under the hood of cyan lies a monte
carlo algorithm which accepts the ode
model and the probability of correctness
so default probability value is always
0.99 and of course users can adjust it
the value will affect the runtime
so the higher probability of correctness
the slower it might become
and the
input ode model is transformed into a
polynomial system from which we first
extract the local identifiability
information and then from the local
identifiability information in further
transforms of the polynomials we can
compute grammar basis and determine
global identifiability
report
in the structural identifiability.jl
package we've got a similar input
structure so we provide a model with
outputs
and the probability of correctness p
however the process of determining
identifiability is a little different
where we
compute something called input output
equations so we only consider equations
that contain inputs input functions
output functions and their derivatives
and then the
the identifiability report is based on
the
coefficients from the equations the
field of coefficients
um now the structuralized viability
package can distinguish between single
and multi-experiment identifiability and
we'll see where this is beneficial and
both can be
can lead to a incorrect answer so
right now let's move to a coding example
so i did preload a few packages like
structural identifiability and modeling
toolkit as well as some other things
that we're going to use to
visualize what's going on with
identifiability so let's first
create
a simple ode it's based on the example
from the slides where there are three
there are going to be three parameters
now and two states
um so we're going to create the array of
equations
and this is by the way all coming from a
modeling toolkit so this is a modeling
toolkit based format for the input value
um at the end of this representation
i'll also show the
structural identifiability kind of
native a slightly different input format
so let's define a modeling toolkit ode
system
and define the array of measured
quantities so these are the outputs that
i talked about in the beginning so we'll
start with analyzing local
identifiability first
so
if i run the assess local
identifiability function and provided
the measured quantities
first it's going to pre-process the ode
system which means that it's going to
convert it to the data type that's
accepted by internals of structural
identifiability
um okay so this is uh done let's
consider let's see the result
so it tells us that a and b are local
identifiable so the output of this is a
dictionary
from the symbols to
the boolean value
c is not not locally identifiable and if
it's not locally identifiable it means
that it's not going to be identifiable
at all
and it does make sense we consider the
output like we measure something that
only
in the ode depends on a and b so no
information about c was provided which
is
why we would not get any information
about it so let's
compute another identifiability
result this time we're going to get a
full picture so local global and
non-identifiable all together
so again it starts with pre-processing
and it's going to go through the stage
of local identifiability and it begins
the input output equation computation
um and then
there's a lot of internal information
about what's going on with the bronze
screen computation and and so on it's
finally done
so it tells you in about roughly nine
seconds we got the
global identifiability result let's
see
okay so as before
let me put the equation up on the screen
so we have a being locally identifiable
and b global identifiable c is
non-identifiable so that result is
preserved okay so let's consider a
slightly more complicated example
so this model comes from oscillatory
behavior in enzymatic control processes
paper
let's define the states parameters and
the equations
so there are four states and we're going
to use a single output so we're just
going to measure the first
state
okay um we'll define the ode system and
let's assess the full identifiability oh
and it's already done in less than a
second um
if we display result we see that
um almost everything is globally
identifiable i believe b
c and sigma are global identifiable beta
and delta are local and alpha and gamma
are not identifiable now i want to focus
on these for a few
for a couple of minutes just to
visualize what this means so let's give
it um let's actually solve the ode
so let's provide some initial conditions
uh let's give it a time span and some
parameter values and let's define the
ode problem that we're going to solve
and plot so the idea is to illustrate
what we're going to do is we're going to
plot the
solution for two collections for two
sets of values so as you can see i'm
gonna alter uh alpha and gamma which i
remember they're not identifiable so um
we should
be able to well actually we shouldn't be
able to see anything changed uh on on
the
um on the picture on the plot so let's
visualize what's going to happen
um and i will in the meantime
alter the parameters
so
for now it's just going to plot a single
solution and and remember that we're
plotting the thing that we're measuring
um otherwise that wouldn't necessarily
make sense
um okay so here's okay here's a function
um looks like um
kind of decreases real fast very nice
let's create a new
oe problem with changed values of
parameters
and let's plot that as well
um
oh all right
let's see oh okay as you can see even
though i change the parameter values the
curves are almost identical i mean
they're probably even exactly identical
so
the parameters are unidentifiable and so
we wouldn't be able to tell that from
the um
ode now let's also uh show another
feature of structural identifiability
where we can check a parameter function
of parameters for identifiability in
this case i'm going to ask well is alpha
plus gamma or alpha plus g identifiable
if i run this
it does the check and the result is
displayed here in the terminal and it
tells me that no it's actually not
identifiable
um so the reason why this might be of
use to check a function of parameters is
because if
parameters
some parameters may not be identifiable
there may be a function
that
that can be identified
um
[Music]
okay so now let's consider an example
where we use the structural
identifiability
native kind of inputs i'm going to zoom
out just a little bit to show the full
oe
so it does kind of look like what you
would expect to be written on paper
i'm going to close the
plots here
all right so if i hold this it's going
to define ode give you a quick summary
of states parameters and output
functions
and if i call it assess identifiability
on that
i see a warning
saying that
the result that it provides and let me
display the result
might be only valid for a multiple
experiment case
well the result that it tells me is k1
is globally identifiable so is k2 and eb
as a quick note let's check with this
identifiability for these two functions
and this time
we didn't see any warnings
and locally these functions are nicely
identifiable so it's another example of
where
you can identify two functions of
parameters now let's go ahead
and
follow the warning so the warning told
us to actually use cyan to
check identifiability of the set model
cyan is the second package that i
mentioned in my slides
that also is very well integrated with a
modeling toolkit uh one notable
difference for now is that we still have
to define outputs in the definition of
variables um but we are working to make
it more compatible with um or more
similar to how uh structural
identifiability does it where you just
provide a separate array of equations
so let's define the equation set
create the system
and
call the main function of cyan called
identifiability ode
okay
all right so um
let me actually display the result
um
okay no i think now it works
okay so yeah um
it starts with a similar process of you
know pre-processing and converting the
input from the multi-toolkit format to
the
appropriate data type
it does start with the local
identifiability report and then proceeds
to the global identification report and
as you can see
so before structural identifiability
told us that these three
were global identifiable
but that was only valid for when you
perform more than one experiments
turns out that if you perform a single
experiment you only get identifiability
uh local but not global
so let's try to mitigate this so i'm
going to define this again
and what i will do is i will generate a
replica in fact i'm going to consider
the input to be
two odes but with different initial
conditions so if i do that
and
okay so the replicas are generated i'm
going to call my function again however
i will
specify the parameters
of the model without initial conditions
well because if we did track initial
conditions that would be two separate
sets and maybe it would be um not as
interested and as interesting as some
other things that we're going to see
so now after performing two experiments
so two copies of the input model we get
the same identifiability result
um as structural identifiability
so that kind of concludes the slide
sorry the live coding section
and to conclude um we
saw two available solutions for
parameter identifiability and ode models
there isn't a one framework that would
solve everything so these kind of
complement one another
some may be appropriate for more output
functions
some would be
faster when there are fewer outputs and
and more equations more odes
but both can handle quite large systems
we've got a lot of work
planned for enhancement of the
underlying rubber basis computations and
integration with more
saml
frameworks
we also currently have a maple based
solution on the web that combines these
algorithms and some more
extensions
and we're also building a julia
web-based solution for the
um
for the web
that's all i have thank you very much to
the organizers and um here are some
references that i used
thank you yeah thank you very nice talk
um so i think we've got a little time
for some questions since you started
late um so there were a couple on
discord so the first one was asking um
uh can you use this with in combination
with a turing.jl model that you know
involves odes
right um
i don't
think that right now it would be
compatible but it's something certainly
we would uh
consider looking into
um
[Music]
they're yeah so it's not right now it
would be like to give a short answer not
right now but um that certainly would be
interesting to um
look into more how to make them
compatible with uh audis that may be um
coming from touring um
um one of the uh other discord questions
was asking if you could say a little
more about the maybe the the notion or
the differences between global and local
structure and structural identifiability
yeah so
so
when
um let me actually maybe con consider
this example
so the biggest difference in between
local and global is that um
when you if you were to solve this
equation um you would actually like
maybe if you even if you don't have the
value of b right if you have x dot
equals a squared times x if you solve it
you can find the value of parameter a
but
because a is squared in the ode you will
be able to identify a squared uniquely
but not um
the value of a itself right because
whatever a squared might be equal to
maybe actually let me
write it down so
if you have if you identify a squared to
be
something
then a will have plus minus that value
right well
two square root of something so there
are two values however a squared is
identified uniquely so that would be
global identifiability when there's one
solution and um a local identifiable
parameter is i have more than one but
financially many solutions i
hope that clarifies
the question i hope it did
um okay i think we got one from the from
youtube at least i think that's the
source uh asking uh can you do
identifiability of initial conditions
yes so uh initial conditions are
identified by cyan
so cyan actually considers the output
functions themselves and the initial
conditions will come from from here a
structural identifiability doesn't check
for initial conditions because the
underlying um
equations that it considers are input
output equations so they only contain
y's and if
i don't have an example with an input
function right now but if there was an
input function well maybe b is an input
function right so there wouldn't be any
state left basically in
the during the process of
identifiability uh computation with um
structural identifiability so to answer
shortly cyan can identify initial
conditions um structurally fabulity
cannot and the difference is because of
the underlying algorithm
uh
okay actually we just got another in um
so can can the parameters be an array
and if so uh is identifiability the same
for all elements so i'm not i'm not sure
maybe you know exactly what that's
asking
um so if
right so i'm uh if i if i understand the
question correctly
let's say you would like to define a
parameter uh q that would go from one to
some number
apparently this type of symbolic
definition just is not supported uh but
we have
we kind of we're working on
supporting this
and resolving the issue
um so if that is what you mean by a
parameter array then it's not supported
right now
um but it will certainly be supported in
the future we'll work on that
cool um i think i actually had one
question myself which is uh i don't know
the kind of relevant theory or
algorithms in this area but is there
much work uh and kind of known good
methods if you have stochastic problems
like sdes for example instead of odes or
jump processes which is what i simulate
a lot
right so um
i don't really work with stochastic
differential equations i i don't think i
can answer the question i believe there
are
works um but i don't think i would be
uh i don't think i know enough of i'm
not familiar too well with them to kind
of give a solid answer um but that's uh
definitely worth looking into i believe
there are uh
there is research done but um i just
personally don't work with stochastic
surprise equations
okay great well then i uh i guess we'll
stop there it's probably it's about time
to start our next talk and so thank you
again for a really nice talk thank you
very much
all right and uh
our last speaker of this session
is uh utkarsh um i i apologize if i hope
i got your name right um
who uh is going to tell us about
parallel extrapolation methods and i'll
let you get going so we can kind of try
to stay on time so
yeah sure so hi everyone i'm utkarsh so
i'm currently a senior at iit kanpur and
i've been majoring in two very different
fields electric and chemical and i've
been
uh coming to mit and working with julia
lab
so yeah so
i believe like let us you know kind of
start introducing like what are
basically extrapolation methods so like
like as the name say it kind of
extrapolates the solution so
so i just you know have this snippet
from the here like which basically you
know explains all the things very
detailed in that so i'll just briefly go
through it
uh so what extrapolation method is
basically it kind of compute the
corresponding step uh by basically you
know choosing a particular subsequence
and as you can see that it has uh
it uh basically you know except
extrapolates to the
t i comma one and which basically kind
of eliminates the
as many terms that which are possible in
the f asymptotic expansion by computing
the interpolation polynomial and finally
uh so basically it helps just to you
know reach higher orders and it is also
a variable step method as well so it
kind of operates in both domains
and like so these methods are now part
of the ordinary difficult
uh
system so it supports all of the
all of the all of the functionalities
that we have the linear saw the
threading multi threading as well as
some some area which i would be going to
discuss like which was uh kind of you
know explained in the here and uh so as
you can see that these are some other
two methods like uh with that one of
them is explicit like which don't uh
whether basically use for non-stiff
problems so these are some of the
methods that we have and uh
uh and another methods are the implicit
methods so that is that would be kind of
my focus for this talk and like
like we kind of you know identified a
domain for domain from these problems
and uh yeah so they are kind they're
performing well but yeah the work is in
progress and yeah it could get better
and uh coming to that
so
i'll basically jump right into it like
uh the od code is everything written in
the auditifique jail you can check it
out and
and every implementation is there but
let me you know come to that like how we
are paralyzing them so we basically
choose a step number sequence like as i
had already told that we need to you
know have smaller step sizes so that
smaller step size extrapolates to the
bigger step size that we are taking at
that point then basically this
then this computation of t k comma 1
requires 2k sequential function
evaluations so this is this kind of a
text that i have
basically kind of error hypothesized and
if we are using mimd processors multiple
input multiple data then this kind of
this serial evaluation can be you know
processed into k processors and
which will basically generate the
numerical approximation tkk and
after that and so basically this kind of
paralyzes our core and the extrapolation
that we are kind of the final time step
that we are following kind of you know
uh exposes the multi-threading and
parallelism apart from apart from the
alien factorization that you would have
in the implicit implicit method
so yeah
that being that and yeah i have just you
know put a uh put down put down some
code snippet as well so as you can see
that we are
so we are calling we are calling the
jacobian 2w on on the on a particular
thread and which basically uh performs a
linear solve and uh and this linear
solves kind this linear source kind of
you know computes the compute the step
at at that point and
then it basically for uh then then this
file then whole collection of this uh
extra extrapolated variables take place
and we finally reach to the
uh these to the kind of
approximation of the method that you are
trying to have
so
so what is this what is so special about
like i mean uh this is like kind of
already been uh you know discussed in
books and as well as these methods are
quite popular so what happened is that
when we are using large set of ods so
in case of uh you know stiff ods
let me be particular to that so
we will require uh
we require a lu factorization that o and
cube solve and what would happen is that
so this is being done by blast so blast
multi threading is not so efficient uh
in like let us say like this is kind of
in heuristic in less than 100 ods so
this would require multiple value
fractionation that scales like o and q
so we know that the inverse kind of you
know goes in o and q so there would be
uh let us say that there would be
there would be a cut off
that point where it's no longer a good
idea i mean there is a kind as we know
there is a overhead in the uh
parallelism that we have
so and also the jacobian is too small to
paralyze in the lu factorization
effectively so it becomes a sealer
solver for sufficiently small problems
so in that case like uh rodas method
would be more serially efficient but
these methods could expose parallelism
to be faster on multi-core machines at
that point
and so that's why our implicit uh
implicit extrapolation methods come into
place
and we know that uh glass is already
multithreading efficiently so a serial
method is already using its own course
and coming to that like as i have
already uh already mentioned this
this is basically
it is important in
quantitative system pharmacology models
because these applications use gradient
based optimization on descriptions of
size such that the optimization nature
requires a parameter choice to be solved
serially so
thus parallelism needs to be exposed
from the solver that's why these
extrapolation methods kind of you know
work in that in that qsc modules domain
and we need to you know also take care
about the size that we have
so yeah coming to that so now basically
it's mostly benchmarks now and i'll
maybe kind of walk through the
benchmarks that we have so
this is a rover problem let me come to
that first so the rover problem is uh is
a stiff problem when it is composed of
three ods so this is generally so this
benchmark was you know uh took upon
taken upon on high tolerances and as you
can see that uh there's implicit error
water extrapolation method so this is
basically a midpoint
midpoint method which we see that the
each small step size is using is being
computed by the midpoint rule and uh and
this is kind of an and this is implicit
so basically as you can see that it is
kind of you know uh
kind of performing
well and
for some tolerances with the rodas which
is the best which is the best solver
that that the problem has so
and even even you can see as input
implicit euler extrapolation so that is
that kind of also performs well but
as you can see that we have this kind of
suite of solvers so that can be you know
tailored according to your problem that
we have how much stiff it is and etc
coming to them so this is a csv model
that i would be going to discuss in the
next slide so as you can see that this
is was compute on low transfer and you
can see that this completely
beats the other solvers that are in this
domain uh even the rosin block and the
tr vdf which works in the in this
in this method so
so this is the kind of the
which basically explains my point like
this is the kind of the domain of this
methods like and where the where the
users can benefit from them
and
coming to that so basically here are
also implemented this in the fortran as
well so these are the sodex and the clx
methods so basically i have i have
included a link here so you can check
them out so we had we have we have good
fortran drivers so od interface and od
interfaces dcq as well so
that is uh that is so that is being
benchmark here as you can see that
clearly
beats the already existing photo solvers
is kind of you know standard testimonial
to the already difficulty solvers that
we have like the benchmarks are pretty
amazing and you can check them inside my
benchmark as well so it kind of amounts
to the five five times per homing
so
yeah and so it is
pretty good according to that so i'll
now you know talk about the brush later
problem so basically it's it's kind of a
pde which is being semi-discretized to
generate an od and we can you know we
can you know
generate indeed in our own sense like uh
that could be you know that distribution
is on to us and that you know kind of
scale that so that problem so that
problem size kind of scaled as n square
so i took this i took this example as
well so this is uh this is stiff so
basically demonstrate that the as you
can see it is near the 100 range so 128
od is pretty near that range and what is
happening is that uh the iron and the 38
versions are being uh uh are performing
very uh are performing much better than
the and third one so that kind of gives
us a 40 to 50 for 40 to 50 performance
game and uh
and coming to that uh i mentioned
polyester thread there so yeah so
basically
polyester threads are the threading
utility which is being provided by julia
swim so uh courtesy of dr chris elrod so
that has been incorporated with them so
the overhead overhead basically in this
thread multithreading is kind of reduced
now so if you can see that
uh comparing
comparing the
polyester threads over the thread so you
can use polyester polyester thread for
this use case as well so that is kind of
an api that we have and also we uh also
coming to the api we also support uh
sequence step uh uh sequence maximum
order minimum order so these orders can
go to very high orders like around 15
orders
and the extra
and uh
and basically we can also select the
sequences which are the harmonic
rhomboh every so what has been you know
given given by the book so it supports
and it can be you know
tuned as per your problem so that is the
kind of the aim of providing a
comprehensive api to that
and uh
yeah so
yeah and so basically i also tested with
this another method what are the euler
very sensory methods so one of one guy
uh i guess he did his thesis in the very
central extrapolation kind of
implemented some of the explicit methods
so my job was to you know
translate them into implicit methods and
we are using very centric extra
extrapolation in it so it performs
similar to this
uh similar to the hair and warner
methods that basically which uses the
midpoint method and this uses the euler
method
and this kind of gives the performance
improvement in it
and coming to the usb model that i was
talking about so basically
uh with the help of modeling toolkit and
systems uh sbml toolkit.jl so i was able
to you know
parser models which is basically usb
models this model describes and compares
two models on the egfr signaling so that
is kind of a protein receptor thing so i
i am not specializing to that but yeah i
uh so
it kind of has around 109 ods so which
basically falls into our domain and as
you can see that uh it it supports all
the things in modulators the structure
simplify so that is the i mean
that is so that is the that is the
advantage of building into this iml
ecosystem
and
you can see that
it has a it has a very significant 80 80
performance increase with multi
threading so you can get so and that at
that application kind of depends on the
number of
number of core as well so like how much
so if you have a higher core count you
can you know get much more better
performance and uh yeah so
i mean you can try these so you can try
this method the implicit method on the
systems from pharmacology models
yeah so
coming to coming to like summarizing
like the thoughts that i have so every
method has its pros and cons so the pro
let me come to the pros uh first so
basically this is this is good for usb
models having 8200 ods and if that that
range is
kind of in heuristic like maybe as
i've demonstrated to the breastplate it
can go to even 120 ods as well so it
leverages higher core count apart from
the early factorization that that is
already take place so we kind of
turn it off uh turn it off in the
implicit method that we have sold every
so so so that
the cores are being blocked by the value
factorization so it is good for highly
stiff problems and precision if you want
to go for very high or very high order
methods so
these methods are quite good so you can
get good accuracy and precision so this
can go up to 15 the non-threaded version
like i have also demonstrated in the
rover problem as well the non-threaded
version performs comparable to with
commons to 4d method so that is a i mean
yeah it's not bad
that it is that it has a very trade-off
in the performance but yes
uh we can you know check on the models
that we are building and uh you know
subsequently decide what to do so the
con is that like what i feel like the
domain is quite restricted i mean they
are better better stiff methods
available for most of the general
problems like
like from sundial.gl there is the cv or
dvda method which
very well and we have an equivalent
which is a better method which is the q
and df in the you know
in the audient disabilities which is
completely
implemented in julia and they are the
rodas method as well as five rhoda's
four so these are i mean in speaking in
general sense like it is uh it is kind
of domain restricted so this threading
overhead becomes significant
in less than 100 ods so you'll the solve
will basically be not you know very good
and it is overcome by so this so this uh
this overhead does not stay as well with
the problem so we are
when we you know go with a very high
very high order problem so then it would
you know uh that performance gain would
you know be substituted by that
so yeah i mean and we are working on
that so and and it still supports the
new assault.jail new interface with
which imel has so we can use multiple
factorization methods and the
pre-conditions that that are being built
upon on that and yeah so it's some of
the work is in working progress and we
are trying to get a preprint and a paper
out of it
yeah so
acknowledgements i i would like to thank
all of these people so which are which
would help and then the guidance is
kindly a new venture to me and
yeah thank you
uh
hi uh very nice talk uh thank you very
much and um
so uh i guess i i had a question you
mentioned a little bit about that at the
end about kind of what's next but so you
see your conclusion is that you felt
these methods were kind of a little uh a
little restricted in terms of the size
of systems
so
so um do you have ideas on how to make
them more generalizable or do you think
it's better to look at some of these
some of the other approaches you know
like used by cv uh yeah i mean i mean i
think some things uh could be done from
the linear sol like that is the
most expensive step because we are going
to the higher orders so the linear and
we are establishing to uh so higher
order so that nelson would grow grow as
as as per that so maybe some if we use
some uh technique some
some tricks in the linear salts that
could be improved but yes i i mean yeah
that is kind but like what analysis we
have so that is kind of uh restricted to
this to me
okay
um well i think that's about it uh for
questions i think everybody's ready for
their break uh so thank you talk um i
guess we'll see everyone in 10 minutes
for the sponsor talk by julia computing
at 1 30 eastern standard time
[Music]
is
[Music]
so
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
do
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
do
so
[Music]
[Music]
we'll wait for one more minute before
you you can get started jacob
um
but i see you have uh you've shared your
slides as well as your screen separately
so i'm just curious whether you want to
put both of those together um i don't
know whether you're going to be
switching back you know between slides
and and screen
or you're muted by the way
oh
now i can hear you you can hear me now
yep okay yeah i'm going to switch so uh
go through a couple slides and switch
back to my screen
okay uh would you
should i just add your um should i add
this picture to the the stream instead
or should i have this
let's let's start with the slides okay
um
when i kind of jump into the live demo
i'll uh i'll use the other screen
yeah for sure just just let me know and
i'll and i'll switch it
absolutely all right i think we've uh
it's 1 30. so let's get started um it's
my pleasure to welcome jacob vaverka
from julia computing and he's going to
be telling us about
m julia computing is the sponsor of
siamel khan as well and we thank we
thank them for their sponsorship
thank you and thank you for having me
and today
uh the name of this talk is
democratizing seminar odes what i want
to talk about is how julia computing is
bringing a platform in julius sim
in order to bring
a lot of the advancements to
many different areas many different
fields many different teams that it
previously wouldn't have been
capable so with that i'll get started
and um
as we know the julia community is
growing rapidly
it's finding its way more and more into
machine learning
in different
industries and
julia computing
is built on top of a foundation of julia
hub which is an enterprise compute
platform
for distributed compute
it's embarrassingly parallel it's cost
effective
and it is all designed around
reproducibility and optimized for julia
development in particular
and so
the
the flagship the
the foundation of julia computing is
julia hub and
on top of julie hub we have many
different tools for different industries
so
we are going to be talking about julie
sim for physical simulations
but there are currently other offerings
for uh pharma simulation for circuit
simulation
there's certainly more to come in the
future but today we're going to take a
look at julius sim in particular
and to start uh we're just going to kind
of walk through
what you might expect if you are in
modeling uh especially with an industry
um
engineers are going to
and they're going to incorporate
modeling into their design process by uh
by leveraging hpc leveraging compute and
uh you know modeling the problems
they're gonna
take these outputs
analyze them and feed them back into the
design so
when this works well
you have
data driven decisions that are driving
your design forward
and
this works really well when you can
experiment quickly and and constantly
iterate
the big challenge here is that
many industries have
they're held back in certain places
where they're dealing with long-running
models
and accelerating that isn't always easy
so
just because you have more compute
available doesn't mean that you're
automatically going to be able to get
that speed up
and
uh it's doable but it's it's time it's
effort
you're always also going to want to make
sure that your model is
still got the fidelity that you're happy
with and so
what we're looking at here is an answer
to this problem this challenge of
pushing industry industrial modeling
forward
because we want engineers to have that
freedom to experiment to ask questions
that may be more feasible to ask before
and
and uh see what designs come out and we
believe that
by enabling this by giving engineers
better tools we're going to wind up with
better designs
and so
this introduces the concept of
a semi-neural ode or a surrogate
also sometimes called digital twins
and this is um i'm gonna talk through
this at a high level this isn't meant at
all to be
uh your um
your your in-depth explanation for this
kind of a crash course
just on what to expect because
later on we are going to be kind of
fine tuning some of the parameters and
so i just wanted to give a visual
representation
of what's happening and
this is
a representation of uh the ctesn the
continuous time echo state network that
uh
chris uh christopher caucus yingbo many
others at julian computing
have all worked on
this algorithm
in order to
train and generate circuits
and so you can start with
you can start with your solutions you
have some weights going in
the reservoir is something i want you to
take note of that's going to be a
particular um
parameter that we're going to adjust
later and then
um in the middle in the in the
in the purple time series where we
integrate that's where the continuous
comes from because we're evolving
this uh differential equation over time
um
and it's it's all fed from these hidden
states and then at the end
we take the output weights
and have a
projection back to the state dimensions
so
again this is um just kind of a crash
course
take note of of the reservoir take note
of the input because this is
i'm trying to represent how
this mental model that you might have
if you are
using julia for your modeling
and um and then if you have more
questions in particular about the ctesn
there's there's papers and other talks
out there that will that will deep dive
that
and so
um
with that kind of out of the way let's
just talk about a general use case where
you have
a simulation that takes two hours
and
two hours one time isn't so bad but
we're talking about an instance where
this two hours
explodes because you wind up having to
run the simulation many many times in
order to find optimal controls
and so
this this two hour simulation
must be run one thousand times in this
workflow
and
it's i think it's
uh it's very common depending on what
modeling that you're engaged in but um
you know
the the exact numbers here are what
we're going to use walking forward just
through this example to kind of share
why the work that we're doing is is
important and what kind of platform
we're trying to build to answer this
challenge
so that two hour simulation run a
thousand times
in addition to one final run at the end
to uh kind of test run just to make sure
that
uh everything looks good and and your
validation run
winds up being 2002 hours
and
this is obviously something that we're
trying to improve so what we propose
here with the solution
is injecting
uh
injecting julius sim in the beginning of
this process and so
what we want to do is we want to train a
surrogate
first right out the gate train a
surrogate and that's going to be done
in order to get a faster
model so instead of running that
two-hour simulation a thousand times we
wind up with something that can run in a
minute
now
training the surrogate
is something that we can kick off in
parallel and again that's something that
julie hub
the foundation of julius cim is very
very good at and so we can leverage
julia
to kick off thousands of simulations in
parallel
and
really only have about four hours
of training time in this example
in and
then you wind up with a one minute
simulation
which
after a thousand runs is about
um just under two hours uh one and two
thirds hours
and so
what we're talking about here is
yes we've cut down time but
aside from just looking at it from pure
compute where
we're looking at wall clock time
um
2000 hours is is days it's it's you know
it's really weeks because you're not an
engineer not just going to be sitting
there waiting for the next one to run
you don't always have the ability to
just make sure that they run
sequentially because you're going to
have to
you're going to have to step in
different places
do some analysis do some fixes
and so that
2000 hours turns into likely weeks or
maybe a month where now
when we're able to do these 1000 runs
with a one minute simulation
we can take that down to just a couple
hours
and so
we're still going to do a test run a
validation run at the end of it
that's our our two hours on the right
but we've taken
what could be weeks or months or
a month
down to a single working day and that's
the difference in
uh
in a industrial setting
that's the kind of thing that can really
accelerate a team so allow them to ask
those questions that maybe previously
they didn't have the bandwidth or the
time to do because
you know their project is on a
particular
life cycle and you know they got to get
their things
out the door
with the analysis that they're able to
do
so
this is what it can look like by
injecting julius cim at the beginning of
this process
bursting one time compute getting that
surrogate that accelerated model then is
going to benefit you
throughout every one of those 1000 runs
to optimize
so that's what we're doing and then
quickly i just want to talk about
where this has been done already and
we have
seen extraordinary speedups for
hvac models
this is an example of a 570x speed up
on a uh
this is
a 8 000 equation hvac excuse me 8 000
equation hvac system
and
we've scaled this up even further to a
hundred thousand equations so when when
we did that we got an adx speed up
and
80 doesn't sound as good as 570 maybe
but when you take into account what the
current tooling is capable of
right now the best you can hope for is
is uh
real-time compute so if you wanted to
simulate a year it would take you a year
to use that now with an 80 time speed up
you can simulate a year with in within
four days so
um
that is really what we're talking about
changing
you know what's possible for uh for
engineers and and and modelers to ask
and uh
and then we this has also been applied
to uh circuit systems as well so there's
a 1200 equation surface system that got
a 274 times speed up
and there's really no limit to where
this can go so
um we're looking to
apply this to as many industries as we
can to
spread these benefits
and so
uh what i'm going to run through really
quickly is just an example of this model
here that you see of a dcpm motor and
it is just measuring the influence of uh
armature temperature
on performance
and uh just note the model parameters on
the bottom right so we have voltage and
we have load
and um
we're gonna see how we can train a
surrogate
over this model with these parameters
and we're again we're going to be using
that ctesn
algorithm and so here
if we could switch back to
my other screen
perfect
alright
so from julia hub we have the julie sim
fmu accelerator application
and once you launch that up you can
connect to it
and then you're faced with a dashboard
and
i guess let me back up just for a second
there's two entry points for this so
let's say that um you're you're writing
this model in code that's great i'm
going to talk about how
you can reap these rewards but if you're
if you're not writing it
in code per se you're using a gui tool
or maybe you're not writing it in julia
if you can generate an fmu
a functional mock-up unit
which is
available from virtually every modeling
tool
then you can take that fmu and upload it
here and get an accelerated fmu in
return so i'm going to show you how to
do that by clicking new job
i'll upload an fmu
so this is a functional mock-up unit of
that motor
model that i showed you
and then
we have the ability to
adjust some parameters for this
surrogate training process so
we are going to use the
uh the algorithm that i shared with you
and then remember that reservoir so
that's the number of
hidden nodes in here so we can adjust
this to
how many we think is going to is going
to be appropriate for our model
the number of simulations that you want
to run
you can
tell it
the time span to run over from beginning
to end and the step
and then you can also enter the
parameter space now instead of doing
this manually i'm just gonna load
a configuration for the sake of time
and we will
just take a look down here
so here are the the load and the voltage
parameters that we saw in that model
and we have a lower bound and upper
bound and a sample point
so if you define these you're going to
define
the parameter space that this circuit
gets trained over
and once you're kind of happy with
with these training inputs
if you hit start new job
then you're going to be brought back to
the dashboard you can see all your jobs
you can always come back and get the
configuration that you used
you can get the report which i'll share
in a second and then you can get that
accelerated fmu
so the report is something that i won't
spend too much time on for the sake of
time but i do just want to point out
that our team
has done a phenomenal job of how to
analyze these models and what you're
seeing here is
a really cool way to
to subtract some of the noise so
you can see straight away some different
colors you can just kind of zoom into
where the model is doing
poorly for instance
and uh
see where you want to train this model
over or where it's safe to use this
model with
high accuracy
and so i'm gonna
i'm gonna leave that there for now uh
just in the interest of time
and then
uh the only other thing that i wanted to
jump to real quick is just show that
you have the ability to do this in code
as well so if you are modeling julia
good news you have all of these
configurations and more
where you can choose the reservoir size
the algorithm to use
the number of simulations you know etc
and so this is going to be a very uh
familiar um syntax and and you know the
the same benefits
um
and so
i'm kind of flying through this but if
you could switch back to the slides i'll
just finish up
so
thank you
so all this is
um
showing two different ways to
start with a model and just uh julia sam
and then get back another accelerated
model so this fmu
that we've accelerated
can be uh put back into existing tools
for whichever you know whichever tools
you're using in your workflow so um all
those different tools that can import
export fmu's can again leverage these
accelerated models
and then this is all made possible again
um because we have the ability to
computation burst on july hub and so
that's the real benefit here is
we are bringing
not only the
the know-how so you know um
instead of requiring in-depth knowledge
of the particular area that you model as
well as
the latest machine turning machine
learning techniques as well as you know
hpc infrastructure
this is really simplifying a lot of that
we can auto scale
to
however much compute that you might need
for your model um we can handle all the
parallelization
um we can also put it back into a format
that
you're currently working with and so
all of this is really the julia sim
platform now i've shared with you a
couple different tools
in the fme accelerator and the julius
myde
but
this is the platform this is kind of the
vision and
and this is all in an effort to
accelerate scientific discovery right so
um all uh on top of all the work that
has been shared here um from the other
members at julia computing um
this this is this is the main goal is to
accelerate these discoveries and as many
different industries and fields as
possible
so uh just have a minute or two left and
that's that's it for me
well thanks a lot jacob um
i do have one question from youtube um
so
how do you handle these security aspects
of julio hub and industry
it's a great question and it's something
that
we face every day because
that's something i would say for
specific questions i'd like for
you to reach out to
info juilliardcomputing.com or
any of our sales
personnel but
it's something that we've had to address
on many fronts because of our existing
partnerships and clients right so we're
working in
a lot of different spaces that require
uh
security require compliance require
uh you know data governance there's
there's very tight rules that we're
we're working with all the time and so
it's something that is really at the
core of everything we do um
and yeah i'd say with with specific
questions definitely reach out and we
can we can definitely answer
um what our current uh
strategy is and and you know how we hope
to improve going forward
right
thanks jacob in the interest of time i
think i'll i'll close it out we are
thankful again to julia computing for
being a simol khan sponsor
and now i will move on to the next talk
thank you for having me
sander could you go ahead and start
sharing your screen please
all right
okay looks like that's
you you can see my screen right yes yes
we can see your screen and just
introduce you um
uh now we have uh sanda breggi who's
gonna tell us about learning measured
bifurcation diagrams with uds take it
away
okay thank you very much for the kind
introduction so i'm sandor bergie from
the university of bristol and as i said
i'm going to talk about learning
measured
bifurcation diagram the uds so universal
differential equations
so basically the
this research i'm going to present here
is mostly on using data driven models on
non-linear dynamical systems which is
linked to a project on
creating digital twins which are
essentially data-driven adaptable
virtual counterparts for real-world or
physical systems
and what i found that universal
differential equation models are
especially good candidates as digital
twins because they basically allow for
having a physics-based core that's
that is
uh they allow for incorporating some of
our insight into these models but by
adding a machine learned
structure to the physics-based part we
can compensate for the modeling errors
and potentially reach a very high
accuracy
this is all very promising and i would
like to use these models for uh
non-linear dynamic systems which is
basically the broader area i
do research in so that's
my background
which
are essentially focused on systems uh
undergoing so-called self-exciting
vibrations and
the main complexity with with
these kind of systems that they are um
most typically lead to varying parameter
problems that usually gives an
additional complexity to the
training procedure and i will uh present
one specific application related
to
an engineering oriented field uh air
elastic flutter for which i
carried out a few numerical simulations
but i also
trained some more trainer models on
experimental data
okay but before that i just would like
to give a short introduction on what
nonlinear systems actually are and what
are the problems i'm uh interested in
so basically nonlinear dynamic systems
can be considered
as differential equations in the
following form like we have a derivative
of a state variable equal to some
nonlinear function of the state variable
and some system parameters
i'm considering uh here or ordinary
differential equations but
one can also
take into account or or study
more complex or more exotic type of
differential equations and the equations
can be either autonomous or
non-autonomous if we have an explicit
time dependence in the equations the
important point is that in the focus of
my investigations are
systems which have periodic solutions
and one very common example is the hook
bifurcation which is a feature in
autonomous differential equations and
basically these two bifurcation diagrams
in the bottom of my slides show the
[Music]
typical characteristics
of the two basic cases of the whole
bifurcation the super critical and the
subcritical one
so essentially in bifurcation diagrams
we typically show the steady state
solutions of the system with
information about their stability so in
in this case i highlighted uh the stable
and unstable solutions with different
colors so for example what happens here
that in the super critical case in the
horizontal axis i'm showing a chosen
parameter which is referred to as a
bifurcation parameter whereas in the
vertical axis
in case of
periodic solutions it's typical to show
some sort of a norm
related to the vibration amplitude so
basically here in the horizontal axis we
have equilibria
which
loses its stability at a certain value
of the parameter lambda
and what happens here at the whole
bifurcation that at the
stability boundary there is a stable
branch of periodic solutions emerging
from from from this point and then this
is the supercritical of bifurcation
whereas in the case of the subcritical
bifurcation a similar thing happens but
in this case the
branch of periodic solutions is an
unstable range
and but what
very commonly happens that later on uh
this unstable branch
undergoes the so-called sediment
bifurcation and becomes
stable again and
so basically the reason i like these
diagrams and why these tell us often
more information than
like a simple numerical simulation would
tell
is
because using essentially the
information of
the steady state solutions and their
stability we can also infer what the
transient of the system would look like
and
starting with different initial
conditions from different regions of the
phase uh space of the system as these
arrows basically indicate we can tell
where the where the solution would
converge to and from this point of view
probably the most interesting region is
this one in the case of the subcritical
bifurcation
then we have a so-called bistable
parameter region where we have
a
coexisting stable equilibrium and a
stable large amplitude solution and then
basically the initial condition is going
to decide whether we will see
the equilibrium or a large amplitude
oscillation in the long
in the longer term or in
in
steady state behavior
which are obviously two
entirely different
type of behavior
now uh the important thing is that in in
this case the unstable product solutions
play an important role because they
essentially are attached to the boundary
between the
domains of attraction of the two stable
solutions so that's why it's actually
also important to characterize this
which
can be a bit challenging because this
solution never directly appears in
experiments since they are unstable but
we have a control based uh technique to
trace them so it's actually possible to
get information of them in in
measurements
so as i mentioned earlier and and
i hope that i could make this a little
bit more clear why these are actually
varying parameter problems
and on the other hand these systems are
relevant in several engineering systems
i just
want a few examples
i hope the video is going to start one
is the example i'm going to show some
numerical results of this aero elastic
flutter which is basically the
self-excited vibration of aerofoils
between airstream the other one is
another area which uh i did a lot of uh
research in
is the viashimi which is basically the
self-excited vibration of rubber
tires now as you can see these
vibrations are relevant because they can
either cause
some mild discomfort but in in
some cases if if if you are unlucky then
there may even lead to two accidents
which is which is obviously dangerous so
you would like to avoid them
okay so um
after this introduction i i would like
to move on and introduce
the modeling concept i have
for this type of system so my assumption
is that
we have an
an experiment or a system we are
observing
um which has this kind of periodic
solution so for example a supercritical
hope bifurcation as you can see
in in this example
uh with the bifurcation diagram
and usually the the case is uh within
engineering system that one already has
some sort of knowledge or insight into
how the system actually works therefore
it's usually possible to
come up with a good physics-based model
which at least in a qualitative sense
describes how the system behaves
but usually the case is that uh that
model is is is never 100 accurate so
there's all there's always going to be
some error due to the
neglections and simplifications one has
to make during the modeling procedure
when compared to measurement data so
that's why
i'm adding a universal approximator to
the physics-based part and using a
universal differential equation model to
reach a
higher level of quantitative
accuracy and compared to measurement
data
so
if we take a look at what
our model looks like in terms of
equations
then from the point of view of an
experiment it's
at least to me it makes sense to
divide the system to an accessible and
the hidden part
basically the accessible part meaning
all the state variables and and and
everything about the system which we can
have
which we can measure
and
but as i said um earlier there there are
always going to be some neglections so
it's it's fairly safe to assume that
there is always going to be a hidden
part of the dynamics which we cannot
model so essentially what we do
is that
i consider physics based model for the
access part and try to
find you need to make it as good as
possible and then add
learnable machine learner structure to
compensate for the error between the
measurement data and the
smaller order physics based model
so basically the two types of machine
learned structures i'm considering for
this problem is there are networks for
which i use the d3q flux package in
julia
so in this case basically the model
error and the objective function is
calculated from
the error in the predicted trajectories
compared to the measured ones
various
in the other case when i considered
gaussian processes
it was a little bit different
because in this case
the model
was fitted directly to the right-hand
side of the differential equations which
means i had to use acceleration data
on the other hand gaussian processes
were
more useful in the cases when there was
some noise in the system because they
are essentially um
have a
natural way of considering process noise
process noise in the model
okay so
in the following slides i just would
like to going to present
my results on the
model of elastic flatter starting with
the numerical simulations
so in this case i consider the two plus
one degrees of freedom model of flutter
as
the underlying model of an experiment or
the ground truth if you would like
where basically
um
the two physical degrees of freedom of
this aerofoil here
aerofoil here the heave and the pitch
motion
was considered as the accessible part of
the model
whereas the model had a non-physical
degree of freedom related to the
aerodynamic effects which are considered
as a hidden
part of the model
so basically what i did is to
create it uh two degrees of freedom
physics based model using just the
accessible part the heave and the pitch
motion and added a machine learned
structure to compensate
for the model error
now if
i
consider the the simplest possible case
when i had a deterministic system
then
actually
this kind of
model with a neural network as a
universal approximator turned out to
work really well um so as you can see
basically i was able to train the model
to replicate um
what the underlying model does and and
what the the measured or
or in this case the simulated
periodic solutions
were
but i also added
the bifurcation diagram of the pure
physics-based model just to highlight
that in this case the difference between
the behavior of the ground truth model
and the physics-based core of the
universe a differential equation model
wasn't that
large so in this case i really just
compensated for a small error
in the model so we can
kind of say that okay this work really
well but this was probably not a very
realistic example so i just try to
um increase the complexity a little bit
by considering process noise and in this
case i use gaussian process
as the universal approximator which
still
work quite well
basically the important conclusion in
this case was that quite predictably the
signal to noise ratio was important
um
which
unfortunately also kind of limited the
amount of noise one could actually
consider in the model because
the acceleration data was more prone to
the
prone to noise excitation than the
trajectories
in case
of the neural network-based models
this is basically the reason why i um
use the neural network based model when
i and i try to train the model uh
fracture
measurement data taken from the physical
experiment you can see the right hand
side of my slide
um basically uh pre-conditioning the
measurement data and and and using it as
a quasi-deterministic
uh training data
um and as you can see basically uh it
was it was possible to train
uh universal differential equation model
which could replicate the measured uh
bifurcation diagram so you could say
that
this is a relatively nice result
unfortunately
we found that
that solution was quite sensitive to the
initial conditions of
the training algorithm so actually it
very often
uh converge to a local minimum instead
of a global one and
in this case as you can see the
characterization of the of the system
behavior is
well it's suboptimal as uh as they say
uh so basically this raised the question
how can we actually improve the
robustness
of the training procedure
and
an obvious thing or at least it seemed
to be obvious to me that uh the current
training framework or the training
framework i used previously didn't
really utilize the information that we
are actually dealing with systems with
periodic solutions it was just a result
that kind of indirectly
was in there but there was no direct
information about this so what i try to
do that instead of using an initial
value problem solver
uh as is the case with the diff eq flux
package
i
try to do something similar with the
boundary value problem solver
and i can see i don't have too much time
so i just
try to show the results and wrap this up
quickly
but basically i have a very simple
example of this
then
i'm using the technique of numerical
collocation
and
once again i'm just
comparing the
the identified periodic solution to the
measured data or in in this case it's
actually generated
uh by a numerical model so basically
what i do in this case
and that i'm just trying to learn the
damping parameter
in the duffing oscillator model there is
the other system parameters i fixed
and um
this could be done with uh relatively
good accuracy
uh finding um
finding finding a solution that is very
close
to the original value and and as you can
see the identified model fits uh really
well to the measurement data but this is
uh really just for trying whether this
type of concept could work it's very old
and very early days because
i of course just identified a simple
parameter not really
trained a neural network or or any more
complicated model but that would be the
goal
in this case so to summarize
these things
and my presentation basically this is uh
very much an exploratory study
mostly to find out uh the potential of
universal differential equation models
for non-dynamic systems
and
basically one of the main conclusion i
could draw from from my results is that
it very much depends on the complexity
of the problem so if the difference
between what the physics based model can
do and what we see in the experiment is
small then usually the model tends to
trans these models tends to work well
if uh
the more the the measured behavior is
more complex then we may have further
difficulties and and
and the training procedure is often less
robust
so um
and basically the the
my idea and concept to you to improve
this and tailor this to work well with
bifurcation diagrams would be to to
change uh for uh boundary value problem
solver in the algorithm
thanks very much for your attention and
i would like to uh draw your attention
to a preprint that's uh available on
archive so
you found it interesting then
uh please have a look at that thanks
very much well thanks a lot sander uh
this is a great talk i really enjoyed it
um unfortunately we've run out of time
for questions so if you do get questions
that discord do hop on there and answer
them there
but i will start the next speaker
um
so and i want to very quickly welcome
stefan riddish book
rita bush sorry um
and he's going to tell us about
universal differential equations with
gaussian processors take it away
um hello everyone um first of my
apologies i'm currently
covered is still a thing that exists so
i apologize for my voice and occasional
moments of confusion
so in this talk i'm going to talk about
universal differential equations which
we all know
with
neural networks but now let's talk about
how this could potentially be done with
gaussian processors this is based on
work that i've done with um with paul
gillard as i'm a student at
oxford university for the center of
doctoral training in autonomous
intelligent machines and systems in
collaboration with christian offensina
oglerbaum from the university of
palerborn in germany
um so let's start by talking about the
motivation
and i'm not going to talk all too much
about this because for a lot of
um for basically i think most most of
the listeners here who are familiar with
the sim ecosystem
a lot of this is is
potentially well known
um if you look at the literature then
you will find that a lot of gaussian
process
machine learning papers for dynamic
systems
are learning the discrete flow maps
so there we
we have a function that if you give it a
state gets you the state after a certain
fixed time step
that works very well because it fits
directly with the trajectory data that
we have usually available
and uncertainty propagation is quite
easy because it is just a chain
of
of
functions f
represented by a gaussian process
so there are sort of nice approximations
available there but unfortunately the
step size is fixed you can only have the
step size that you trained your model
with
and because you're learning effectively
the flow map chaotic and complex systems
can be quite hard
especially if there's a sensitivity to
the initial value
so instead let's consider continuous
vector fields
and this is sort of why what we all know
and like
we have
a function and if we give it a state it
gets us back
if it gets us back the gradient at that
location
usually for most odes the vector field
is a lot less complex than the flow that
you get when then you get when solving
it
um and also
if you have the vector field now you can
choose the step size freely and you can
choose the solver freely which is where
if you have the the wide array of
solvers from from the divi queue
ecosystems available
is quite valuable
unfortunately the data to learn these
models is not directly available
as we usually don't have the gradient
observation we only have trajectories
and uncertainty propagation through an
arbitrary solver is very very difficult
um so now to the part that really i
think
i think other speakers have also already
talked about what we want to do is we
want to combine data and model knowledge
um
because that is
substantially more powerful than having
either of those individually
we ideally want a model which can take
data
for um especially terms that are
difficult to describe analytically but
if we have some analytic knowledge or
some assumptions qualitative assumption
that we can make about a system be very
nice if we could incorporate those as
well
combining those two gets us usually or
should should get us better
extrapolation performance
structure that we can potentially
exploit and as a result you often
cheaper training
so
effectively
universal differential equation and
neural networks have shown that that
what i've just talked about can be done
but now let's do it with gaussian
processes
talking about gaussian process the first
thing that we need to talk about is that
i've already mentioned this before we
don't have derivative data available
but gps needs explicit input and output
pairs um
at least sort of in their most naive
implementation
and also for some less naive
implementations
we have trajectory data with with time
steps and states
potentially with noise but now what we
need is states and gradient observations
and a potential option to get these
would be to differentiate along the
trajectory
um and we could do this for example
fighter differences or we do kernel or
gp regression
given that this is a talk about gps
let's just assume we fit a gp to our
time series and then because gps are
closed on the linear operators and
differentiation is a linear operator we
can vary we can analytically
differentiate that time series and get
the derivative information
this is where the many automatic
different differentiation to a framework
that we can find in julia really come in
handy
and
because it is so easy to incorporate
automatic differentiation there's some
interesting
ideas and perspectives for end-to-end
treatment of uncertainty
but more on that potentially later
so in julia specifically
there's already a very rich ecosystem of
uh various gaussian process related
tools
first of all a common problem with gps
is that they are very computationally
intense because the computational cost
scales with the number of data points
that we have available
um a very common way to address these is
to use sparse approximations some of
which are already implemented in the
approximate gps package
and the idea here is that we reduce the
data that we have to only m inducing
points
where m usually is much less than the
number of the total number of data
points so now we only have this cubic
scaling with with the the number of
inducing points that we chose and
potentially depending on how we choose
those um
inducing points we can even get
structure in our kernel matrix which we
can then exploit when we invert it
now we have certain modeling choices
similarly to neural networks where we
can choose the number of layers or the
number of neurons per layer
um and for gps this is the first choice
that we we can make is to choose the
kernel
and there's a
very large number of kernels in the
kernel functions.jl package it is really
i think it's been described as the
workhorse of the gp ecosystem
as most kernels there are very
optimized and they're all
they're all ready for automatic
differentiation
to choose the inducing points that we
might want to use to reduce and reduce
the computational load there's the
package inducing points.jl
which has various methods to choose
inducing points including some online
methods which which can adapt the using
points as more data comes in
and we can also choose different cost
functions some of which are implemented
in the gdp likelihoods package
but i've also mentioned before that we
have the qualitative structure that we
would like to incorporate
and for certain qualitative structures
gps are a very good tool to use
um first of all fixed points in a lot of
instances we know where
the system is at rest
and
if we if we know this the steady state
um for a given system we can trivially
add this to the derivative data set that
we feed into the gp
and i'll show an example of doing this
later
further we can also very nicely
incorporate linear lead group symmetries
there is
a kernel class called the gim kernels
for group integration matrix kernels
which allow us to
if we know that a system has a certain
legal symmetry we can define
a kernel in this fashion
and
um
um sorry um
okay we can we can get this in a um
we can we can define this this uh this
kernel with this uh integral
and then if we define if we then sample
from the resulting gp using this kernel
we're guaranteed that the function that
we get out of that has the symmetry that
we want
for an
example um
here is the spiral ode which some of you
may have already seen in the deep eq
flux
example zoo
and here we compare the top row here are
the gp based approaches we see that in
both cases
they do correctly converge to a fixed
point
here for the right one we have
explicitly added 0 as a known fixed
point and we find that indeed does
converge correctly
here it converges to somewhere else but
critically it does converge
even sort of beyond the original data
that was provided
by contrast the neural network example
seems to go into some sort of limit
cycle
and this is previous work using gps in
um
in odes
but unfortunately it completely misses
even the original data but it does
convert correctly close to zero
on a slightly shorter time time scale
looking at this here we see that the
vector field gets captured quite well by
most methods
but sort of as we could have
expected from the previous slide um the
gp based approaches fit here fit quite
well here
um and we can even get uncertainty
propagate like estimates for the
uncertainty as we start to extrapolate
beyond the originally provided data
unfortunately for this plot
the uncertainty was computed using very
expensive sampling methods
which are not very practical
in most use cases so we're currently
working on some more efficient ways
to make this happen
for an example for incorporating
symmetry let's look at the kepler
problem
um
which is defined by the lagrangian
another which is defined by the
following lagrangian which we can see as
a rotational symmetry
uh and then if we build the
corresponding gim kernel
and then do
then identify the system based on sort
of one rotation of the
um
of the body
we find that it does indeed sort of
fit the the the gp solution does indeed
fit very well
with the
with the ground truth especially
the critical line here to look at is the
brown one it does like the ideally the
the first integral should be perfectly
preserved
the brown line has
shows some
light drift
which is
due to numerical issues currently
so
how does that incorporate into smell
um ideally what we what would be nice is
if it would be possible to just swap in
and out neural networks and gps when
trying to identify a system
so that
um so that one can one can see which
which one works which works better for a
given problem
um
and to do this there's currently two
um
packages that reflect what i've just
shown the first one is gaussian process
odes
that is unfortunate i wrote this about a
year ago it is unfortunately mostly
research code it does work it has
its nice bits but it is not very
extendable
so now more recently i've started to
build gif a gp dvq
um which i hope can be a very
lightweight package to come to really
connect um the existing tools from the
julia gaussian processor processors
organization um as well as dvq and flux
packages
um
[Music]
so that that as all of these parts get
more powerful the aggregate also gets
better
unfortunately there's still a lot left
to do
in the julian julia gaussian processors
organization itself
i would like to improve the multi-output
api
while multi-output processes have been
implemented
i think last year
there's a bit of quality of life
currently missing
that i would like to improve upon
and more approximation models
should be added to the approximate gp
package um and to be to be nicely used
in an ode model um
it should be easier to rebuild the
the gps as as necessary um in
gp dvq um this is currently a package um
that i would best describe as end to end
ready to be fixed
which is a model that i've stolen from
somewhere
um
it sort of does all of the things
broadly that i would like it to do but
now everything needs to be improved
everything needs to be tested better
better documented and more examples
um
all of that then leads to the very big
question i've already mentioned this
before uncertainty propagation
how does one
send pro uncertainty through an
arbitrary solver
um not so trivial even for the for the
explicit euler method um
gets extreme existentially more
complicated with any other solver so i'm
still working on that one
um yeah in summary
gps can complement neural networks when
building universal differential
equations and i hope that at some point
we get to a point where they can be used
very simply and interchangeably
um there are many opportunities to
incorporate additional knowledge and
assumptions in gps that are very
difficult to be cooperate in neural
networks
and julia really is the perfect
knowledge to do this the perfect
language to do this in because there's
already a very extensive gaussian
processors ecosystem
um there is cymel which is why we're all
here today
and it would be very nice if we could
combine all of them
if you have any questions
um about this please get in touch
and i think i am not sure how i am on
time
but i might stop it here now you take
questions you
you have five minutes left for questions
um
so i have one question from youtube uh
already a fussy thank you for the for
the talk this was very enjoyable um
you have you have great pictures on the
slides as well i i really like them
anyway um
so the there's a question from youtube
uh
stefan uh
have you have you sort of done any
experiments comparing you know gps and
polynomial chaos
uh you know type approximators or any
other types of approximators that you
would use in you know uncertainty
quantification
um i have i have not yet but i would i
would like to um i think this is this is
something where again having been being
on the vector field level um
um is much more powerful than being on
the on the flow flow
flow map level that gps usually use that
used on
yeah i i want to but i haven't gotten
around to it yet
all right um
i also have a question from discord
has there been work in hierarchical
methods which try to sort of identify
topological characteristics
and using gp methods to fit based on
identified features i'm not familiar
with with
these hierarchical methods but i would
be very curious um what they are and and
see like i'm sure i actually thought
something could be done yes
yeah i'm i'm sure the person um who's
asking the question on discord is
somebody you could get in touch with and
and and sort of explore further
um
let me see
i uh in the meantime i also had a
question um
how um how difficult it is uh is it to
sort of um you know get these get these
things to converge sometimes uh
you know um
have you you know especially with
arbitrary kernels that you would have in
in in kernel functions is it is it is it
uh
is it difficult depending on which
kernel you choose uh et cetera et cetera
and do you have to do any sort of uh
conditioning of your data for that in
the first place
um so so
that sort of part of my of my motivation
to really build this um this this
package to to to build pardon the
julia processes julia gaussian process
organization is to make it much easier
to trust various different kernels to
really look at like really look at this
sort of very like
very widely um so far like in my old
package where they had to implement a
lot of things myself which sort of
limited what i could do
in my tests so far i found that actually
gaussian browsers are quite like very
very nice to optimize
they have usually much much fewer
parameters
and like it's not like in your network
where you have like 250 500 or so um
optimization variables like sometimes
you can you can get by with only three
um
which means that that optimization can
be very very fast
and yeah and even even then if
there's certain certain methods where
you optimize the placement of the
inducing points which then adds
number of inducing points times
dimension
additional variables even that is sort
of still less than than a typical neural
network might have
so yeah
and i guess uh as a final question
perhaps uh you you said that um you know
uncertainty propagation through solvers
can get very complicated uh you know
especially with the you know with the ex
even with an explicit euler method could
you could you comment a bit more about
that so you know we get a better picture
of what you're saying
well well essentially essentially the
problem is that um
[Music]
a normal distribution mapped to a
nonlinear function is no longer a normal
distribution
usually it is even no longer symmetric
and then the question really becomes how
can you find an approximation that
captures that correctly and and keeps
and even like because because if you
if you do the wrong kind of mistake it
compounds
so you have to somehow find an
approximation that that is is um sort of
sent like stable against compounding in
a certain way that it doesn't make the
same error every time so that that that
error sort of keeps keeps building
and that is currently the the challenge
that i'm that i'm going into um
you if you then allow like an arbitrary
distribution and you just have an
arbitrary distribution through
non-linear function then you know then
you back to sampling methods effectively
um so like sampling is always possible
but it would be nice to have something
that uses like some cheap approximation
but it is currently not clear to me i've
tried a few different things it's
currently not clear to me what that
approximation would need to be
i see that that's fascinating maybe uh
folks have opinions in the in the chat
um but i but i i should thank you once
again uh i know you're not well today
and we really appreciate you coming out
and giving this talk and your and your
voice and everything went went great so
i want you to be assured of that
thanks again stefan
all right all right um our next and
final talk of this session before we
take a break is raj dandikar
um and we're gonna talk he's gonna talk
about uds and epidemiology
hello everyone i hope you can see my
screen
so today i'll be talking about the role
of udes in epidemiology and in doing so
i will introduce a new way to do
epidemic modeling
this work has been done with chris
rakakus and also in collaboration with
george barbastatis here at mit
at the end of this presentation we'll be
able to answer the following questions
number one how different were the kohit
19 quarantine policies implemented by
india and south korea number two how
many infections would have been saved if
the southern u.s states did not reopen
early can we predict the next way of the
pandemic and fourth what is the optimal
social distancing or lockdown policy
which should be enforced
we'll try answering these questions with
the new the new framework with its roots
in scientific machine learning
so i have divided this presentation into
two parts the first part is the ksir
model and its applications and the
second one is the safe blues project
so let's dive into part one first
the sir model is the most traditional
epidemiological model so s stands for
susceptible eye for infected and are for
recovered it essentially uh describes a
transition from the susceptible to the
infected compartment and from the
infected to the recovered compartment so
here you can see the blue dots are
susceptible which slowly become infected
which is shown by the red dots and
finally they become removed and
recovered which is shown by the grey
dots
this interaction is represented by a set
of ordinary differential equations as
shown here
it is because of this that the sir model
is popular because it's very
interpretable in nature
however it has a number of assumptions
one of them being that
the assumption of homogeneous mixing
that is a person's contacts are randomly
distributed among the population there
is no provision to include
non-uniformities like quarantine or
social distancing etc in a person's
contracts however during covet 19 we saw
that it's these very non-uniformities
that really shape an infection growth
curve which is seen in a particular
country
for example if you look at the
diagram of north korea's infection we
can see that due to the aggressive
quarantining and the social distancing
measures which they implemented the
infections were really curtailed after
the first wave
however you can contrast that with the
graph of usa where we can see that there
were number of
peaks
in terms of the infected cases because
of poor quarantining and social
distancing policies
what we really want to do is
now incorporate these complex effects in
the sr model so let's see at a micro
level what such a such an effect would
look like so either it's something on
the left which is
we quarantine or isolate a portion of
the infected population and then we
prevent them from coming into contact
with the rest of the population
or something on the right which
simulates a kind of a lockdown situation
where a person really only interacts
with their neighbors and
is a distance range which we imposed on
the interactions
what we want to do is model these
complexities but without resorting to
complicated agent based models
we somehow want to retain the od
structure which the sr model has but
also simulate these complex effects
the way we will do this is we will
develop a machine learning augmented sr
model which takes into account these
quarantining or social distancing
effects in particular we will look at
udes
so
you may ask how are we planning to do
that so the way we will do this this
will represent this quarantining or
social distancing effects as neural
networks and then learn them based on
the country's specific data
towards the end what we'll see is that
these resulting models which are
augmented by neural networks are not
only expressive but they are also very
good diagnostic tools they are
interpretable in nature which lead to
very powerful
globally applicable diagnostic tools
so let's look at how this ksr model is
constructed
we know what we want to simulate we
essentially want to
isolate a portion of the infected
population and prevent them from coming
into contact with the rest of the
population so intuitively we know that
we need to subtract a term from the
infected population
but we don't know the form which the
term will take
so we'll use a neural network to
approximate that term
essentially the sir model is converted
to something of this form so here you
can see that in the infected compartment
we have a neural network subtraction
term which represents this transition to
this quarantined compartment or isolated
compartment so we have one more
compartment here
and this is the addition additional
neural network
now we want to train this qsr model on
country specific data
to do that we will need to optimize the
parameters of the neural network to
minimize the loss between our model and
the data
to do so we need to take derivatives of
the loss function with respect to the
neural network weights
and for this we'll use the adjoint
equations so adjoint equations
essentially let us calculate derivatives
of uh
functions of ode solvers with respect to
neural network parameters
uh i won't go into too much
detail into these adjoint equations but
basically they are a set of odes and
once we solve them we can get a gradient
of the loss function with respect to the
neural network weights
and then we can perform gradient descent
routines to optimize these weights
all of the modeling which modeling
results which are shown later are done
in the julia language
so now let's look at the results once we
optimize this qsr model we can apply
this to a number of different countries
all over the world
firstly
we can see that compared to the baseline
data the model does pretty well so the
red red bars here represent the infected
population data in the country in italy
and the timeline just to give you a
sense we looked at february 2020 to may
2020 so roughly about three months
and we can see that and the blue is the
recovered data
we can see here that the qsr model
captures the trend in the underlying
data
for both the infected and the required
population
this may not be too surprising since we
have neural networks we expect the model
to be expressive
what is probably one of the important
takeaways from this presentation is this
plot here
if you look at the so first of all this
plot is for china
the black dots here represent the
quarantine strength which is recovered
by a neural network it's the optimized
neural network output and we are calling
it the recovered quarantine strength it
shows this particular variation
the red line is the time at which ramp
up is detected in this
quarantine strength what we noticed is
that this this time is actually very
similar to the time at which a
government lockdown was imposed in china
and that was a great news for us because
if this is true then the model can
really be used as a diagnostic tool
to understand what's going on um in the
particular country now we wanted to test
this particular thing on several
different countries
and we saw that for a wide range of
countries the time at which the
recovered quarantine strength which is
the red line here shows a ramp up in our
neural network optimize function
lies very similar to the time at which
the government lockdown was imposed or
quarantined measures were strengthened
in the region under consideration
we eventually did this for 75 different
countries which is hosted the results
are hosted at this particular site you
can check this out
and we essentially showed that the model
which you developed the qsr model is not
only very expressive in nature but it
can be used as a powerful diagnostic
tool to understand what's happening on
ground in the particular country
so this makes this model pretty
impactful as we have seen over the last
one year
it has been used by in a number of
different areas of various national labs
are using it silicon valley startups
have reached out to us and
academic institutions
are also using it
one of the key aspects because of which
the model
can be further more useful is that it's
flexible in nature it doesn't need to
stick to just the quarantine effects but
there's a for example there is a group
of students at mit who is working on the
vsir or the vaccination sir model in
this they represent the vaccination term
by a neural network and then they are
applying this model to a number of
different countries of the world
this flexibility is also one key
uniqueness of the models constructed
using this
approach rooted in scientific machine
learning
we wanted to further test this model on
to another different setting
so we choose the we chose the time
period of may to july 2020 and we are
especially interested in what happened
in the united states during this
particular period so if you look at this
video we can see that
during may may to july 2020 the cases in
europe were kind of reducing and
stagnating but there was an exponential
explosion in the number of cases which
was seen
in especially the southern and the west
central
united states in particular we looked at
these nine states which showed a huge
surge in the number of infections
now we wanted to ask the question that
can we apply the ksir model here
and can the model recovered q of t be
correlated with early reopening in these
states
and secondly how many infections would
have been reduced if the states had not
reopened early
okay so now we applied this model to
number of different states and first i'm
showing you this plot for the state of
south carolina so there are number of
things to unpack here so let me go step
by step
the red dots here represent the current
neural network recovered quarantine
strength by buyer model it shows a
increase and a subsequent decrease
what's great here is that the time at
which there is a cusp seen in the
recovered quarantine strength buyer
model actually matches very well with
the time at which the stay at home order
expired
in the state of south carolina
this shows that our model recovered
quarantine strength q of t shows a drop
when the state reopened which is here
then what we did was okay what if the
state had not reopened early and what if
its quarantine strength had not
decreased so what if the state had
maintained its quarantine strength at
this particular level what would have
happened
we simulated this particular scenario
for the state of south carolina and we
saw that the number of infections which
are shown by this blue
uh blue line here would have been
significantly less compared to the
number of infections which are actually
seen shown by these red bars
so the second conclusion for this
particular state was that in the event
of a stricter lockdown the infections
could have been reduced significantly
so we had two basic uh conclusions which
we wanted to check for all the states
first
do all the states
for do this for all the states q of t
show a drop when the state reopened and
second in the event of stricter lockdown
can infections have been reduced
significantly in all of these states
first thing which you observed is that
for all nine states which we looked at
our model shows a drop on k of t when
the state reopened
and secondly for all the states which we
considered in the event of stricter
lockdown the number of infections could
have been reduced by significant amount
so this study again confirmed the
validity of the qsr model as a
diagnostic tool
finally in the last
three or four minutes i want to
talk about another project which is the
safe blues project which we did
through this project what we want to
demonstrate was that virtual virus
spread through bluetooth tokens can be
used
as an indicator for real-time estimate
of infection statistics
this study is now being conducted as an
experiment in the auckland university
new zealand
so the main premise was this after
government policy is implemented such as
lockdown mask majors etc it usually
takes a week or two before realizing
whether it's working or not so the
question was can we really reduce this
lag to zero
and this is why we designed the safe
blues campus experiment so how it works
is as follows so let's say there are a
number of students in a college campus
we ask them to participate in this safe
blues experiment once they agree to
participate
they download the safe blues app and
once they do that their phone is seated
with a huge ensemble of strands
a strand has number of properties such
as transmissibility incubation duration
infection duration
and a strand can spread across nearby
smartphone through bluetooth
communication so let's say if two
students meet at the cafeteria
and they interact then there is a and
both of them have safe blue app then
basically the strands can change
properties based on whether it's
infected or recovered
etc
then what we do is we train a neural
network between the historical coed 19
data and the safe blues strands data the
real key here is that the safe blue
strands data is available to us in real
time so if you can train a deep neural
network between the historical data and
the real-time safe bliss data we can
have
a real-time prediction without any lag
of the epidemic trajectory
the key point here is that
biological pathogens and bluetooth both
have proximity as the key factor which
governs their transmission
so we constructed a deep neural network
and we trained it so this plot kind of
summarizes
the conclusions if you look at the red
dots here this is the infected data
which we only have up till this time
whereas the blue strands are the safe
blues
strands which are available to us in
real time so it's available here even up
till year let's say two weeks after
the point during which the infected data
is available
and based on this data we train a neural
network between the infected data and
this wavelength data and then we
forecast
then what we can see is that if you look
at the forecasted data
the prediction which is shown by this
blue line matches very well with the
true data during this time which is
shown by these yellow circles
so i'm going a bit fast through this in
the interest of time but if you have any
questions regarding this please feel
free to reach out
these are some preliminary results which
were done in the auckland university
campus
and at the heart of all of this is a
scientific machine learning framework so
essentially we have neural networks
integrated with the sir modules
which are used for predictions
and this type of safe blues module can
also be used for policy control
essentially we can ask questions like
okay what is the
lockdown strength which is required
which will get the effective
reproduction number to less than one it
should not be too less or it shouldn't
be too high what is the optimal
policy which can be implemented to get
the reproduction number less than one
so safe blues methodology enables us to
get real-time estimates real-time
estimates such as the ones presented
here
so okay in conclusion what we have shown
and what we have seen generally is that
neural network augmented frameworks udes
can lead to powerful epidemiological
models these models are not only
expressive and powerful but also highly
interpretable in nature
and they can potentially replace complex
compartment models
in the future we have an active
collaboration which we are doing with
sandia labs currently to test some of
these methodologies on real data which
they have
and we want to also integrate these uh
ude framework with bayesian modules
so that we can do error quantification
and i would like to thank you for your
time and would be happy to um answer or
discuss any questions
thanks thanks a lot raj um
you could um you could still share your
screen if you if you'd like to skip over
slides um but that's not crucial um
uh it's a great great talk i i mean i've
seen previous versions of the talker i
think you really nailed it this time
it's fantastic uh
i have one question from youtube um
so uh do you do cindy or something
similar to try and identify the symbolic
form of the quarantine term q
yeah so
what we have shown um in one of our
recent studies is that
symbolic recovery can be done on these
models and we can essentially get the
interaction terms like what the neural
network actually represents i plan to
include it in this talk but i thought
that it would extend the time but i will
be definitely happy to chat further
regarding this whoever has posted this
question
yeah it's it's on it's on youtube you'll
be able to find it on the on the live
stream um
uh i uh i have one more question um
why the why the sir models i'm sure
there are like a a million of these uh
these models out there right so why why
do you why do you choose to add neural
networks to that one or why not a
different one yeah that's a good
question actually so first we wanted to
start out with the simplest model
and the sr is one of the simplest
compartment models out there
so it's a three compartment model and
after showing that it works indeed for
three compartment models and now we have
even shown that it works for five or
nine compartment models
so we just chose the sr because it's
simple and now we are moving to more
complicated models
i see so in principle you could you
could use different ones and you'll get
different kinds of inter
interpretability for
exactly exactly
i see
um
and and uh i think we have another
minute so i will i will follow up again
and say hey uh what about the the
vaccine sir model uh what how how well
is it doing do we do we get a sneak peek
of the results there that's a good
question actually so the team who is
working on that i think they started uh
four or five months back
and i still think they are working a bit
more to polish the results but
essentially there is a good comparison
result between let's say the country of
israel
and some other countries
so i think there are some good results
to be expected in that study
well that sounds very very exciting i
think we're at the point where we all
want to see those types of results um
all right i um i think i will close it
off
uh uh close it off now and uh give one
minute to the audience and we have a ten
minute break now
um thanks again raj by the way um
so we have um we have a 10 minute break
now and and we will begin again at uh 3
p.m eastern
all right and see you guys in about 10
minutes
so
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
do
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
all right we are
back
just gonna
rafale i just added you to the stream
along with your slides
um and we can begin
in approximately a minute
sounds good can you hear me well yep i
can hear you well and your slides are
visible
my slides are visible let me check am i
changing the slide now yeah okay cool
yeah you can flip through them if you'd
like as well i mean
yeah
oh look
yeah can i can i start now
yeah let me let me uh
wait uh it's 2 59.
yeah now yeah let me introduce you first
so
um welcome back everyone um
uh it it is our pleasure to to invite
rafael pestori from mit to give us a
talk on physics enhance deep surrogates
that are trained end-to-end
hi
um i am thank you wren chen for the
introduction uh so i am a postdoctoral
associate uh in the
uh mathematics department at mit and
today i'm presenting about physics
enhance uh deep surrogate trained
end-to-end using julia
and this work was done in collaboration
with uh yusuf muay and paell das from
ibm and chris
and stephen johnson um from
mit
and so
uh
what it what is a surrogate model uh it
is a learned model that fits a
particular outcome of a partial
differential equation which i will call
pde
uh and it is not a solver uh that will
compute the solution for the pde
but rather a data-driven model
which will fit a particular property of
the pde solution
for example in
optics
where the
pd
pde
our maxwell's equation um you can see on
this image um a surrogate um
that is fitted to predict the complex
transmission
um
uh through a structure
based on the parameters of the geometry
here the the width of all those little
rectangles over the ten layers that you
can see
and another parameter of the surrogate
model uh
are the is the frequency of the incoming
light um and today i will show uh
results for this specific surrogate
model
um
at evaluation time um
since a surrogate model does not solve
for the pde solution but rather
evaluates a fit uh surrogate models are
orders of magnitude faster than pde
solvers for an application like this one
in optics a typical speed up would be 10
000 times faster in 2d
uh simulations
and
a million times faster for 3d simulation
sorry
and and in practice in optics this
surrogate model is used in conjunction
with uh decomposition methods
for a very computationally challenging
simulation problem such as computing the
light scattered by a ml surface and if
you are more interested i'm not gonna
talk about it today but if you're
interested in into this uh please refer
to my previous work in optics express
um
but but there's no uh free lunch the
fast evaluation uh
time uh comes at the cost of generating
a lot of training data which uh involves
um computing pde solutions many times
and so data generation uh re is really
the bottleneck of high dimensional
surrogate models
note that like surrogate models also
become more costly as the number of
inputs dimension increases but the
bottleneck is the cost of the generation
of the data
so that's what i'm going to focus on uh
in my talk today
and and uh
a first a surrogate model uh traditional
one that works very well for up to four
or five parameters uh is chebychev
interpolation trebuchet polynomials are
great because they are exponentially
convergence for a smooth function and so
it less it requires less expensive pde
solves to train
and and these two images here the top
left and the bottom right um shows that
like the choice of point is important
the strengths of chebychev interpolation
comes from its polynomials and its uh
special
set of training points that you can set
bottom left uh the chebychev points
for the same function uh the top left
image uses chebychev points and the
bottom right uses equally spaced points
and the latter presents a very big
artificial oscillations which are
catastrophe for uh surrogate models
which is called rango phenomenon
and uh here it really shows that um yeah
the choice of points really matters
unfortunately uh
for um
contributive polynomials uh it requires
uh for like a polynomial of degree and
in each direction it requires n plus one
uh points and so for p parameters you
would need n plus 1 to the power of p
points uh to train uh your surrogate
model and so the the number of points um
really quickly becomes intractable as
the number of parameter increases
and this is called the curse of
dimensionality
and so in contrast to polynomials neural
networks seem to alleviate the curse of
dimensionality
neural networks are now very popular it
is an algorithm with thousands to
millions of parameters which take an
input
uh does a bunch of matrix
multiplications composed with non-linear
activation functions on multiple layers
research is still active to understand
why they work so well but they have had
a lot of practical successes in
particular as surrogate models in optics
but again there's a trade-off between
accuracy and training time a neural
network with many parameters might be
more expressive but it will be more
expensive to evaluate and take more data
to train
again today we are going to focus on
elevating the training cost which is
then dominated by data generation
when and why should we use neural
networks instead of brute force solvers
for pdes
in optics at least a lot of people are
trying to use neural network um but our
physics model is great in optics and
like uh for some other problems where
neural networks are used like uh face
recognition
um
and and so in the top left of this slide
uh i show uh uh another french mine a
french man like me andre marie
and in the top right james clerk maxwell
and
them and a lot of other people worked
really hard to have a very good physical
model for electromagnetic waves
and neural networks uh the vanilla
neural networks at this don't don't have
physics in them and so it's very
difficult to compete with physical
models and brute force solvers and often
you are better off solving for maxwell's
equation with a good brute force model
directly
however
surrogate models are a complete case for
using neural networks because they can
be reused millions of time and evaluate
much faster than solving for the pde and
so over time you can amortize the
training cost
and also they seem to and all uh
high dimensional inputs well so it makes
them great candidates for surrogate
applications later in this talk i'm
presenting ways to include the physical
knowledge
of the pdes inside the deep surgery
so today i will focus on the topic of
data efficiency and i will start by
mentioning briefly an active learning
algorithm which i published a couple
years ago and i'm currently expanding uh
coded in julia with ranjan and
entirement
and the question uh for this type of
project is how can we use
feedback from the surrogate model as it
learns to find an efficient set of
training points
uh start with the results here here i
showed a fractional error on a test set
for three models uh in green uh the
chebychev interpolation which uses chip
jeff points and it performs the worst
because it suffers the curse of
dimensionality recall i'm using this
surrogate model introduced earlier with
10 geometry parameters
the orange and blue models are neural
network surrogates which can we can
already see that the neural networks
perform much better than polynomials
and the orange one was trained with
randomly sample points where
whereas the blue one was trained with
points explored using our active
learning algorithm we see that
the blue model which is an accuracy of
seven percent with about 20 uh 12 times
less points than the orange model
showing the effectiveness of our active
learning algorithm
and the active learning algorithm goes
as polo
the training set is initialized with a
few sample a few points and pulled at
random and then there are three steps a
training step first where uh you train
your data model on your current training
set
and you train another model which is
your uncertainty quantification model
which will give you an estimate of how
well uh uh
or give you an estimate of the error of
your data model for your surrogate model
and then you have a second step the
filtering step where you evaluate your
uncertainty model your error estimate on
n times k randomly sample points and you
select only the k points with the
highest uncertainty estimates
and there's a third uh
step where you compute the points but
only for those with highest estimated
uncertainty and then you add those to
the training set
and you repeat this
t times
uh in the result shoulder showed in the
previous slide
m was equal to four so i discarded three
quarter of the randomly samples points
before the pda
simulations and t was equal to eight so
for each data set size the data set was
created by incrementally adding points
to the training set eight
times what is great about this uh
algorithm is its generality it's
independent of the uncertainty
quantification method so you can use it
with a variety of uq techniques and in
fact you only need a monotonic function
of the error
so for example uh
confidence internal interval spread
would work just as well
and it's independent of the pde so so it
can work with any pdes and
we've seen uh already
improvement and reduction in
need for data for maxwell's equation
linear elastic mechanics and the fourier
heat equation
um
and in in the npg article from two years
ago i used an ensemble of peter
scheduling greshams uh whose mean is the
predictor
um uh and uh the
for the complex transmission and the
pool variance is the measure of
uncertainty quantification
uh
and uh here the uh
and here the loss uh function was the
negative log likelihood of the model
um i'm using uh this last function uh in
the next part of my talk
and in this application the model serves
both as predictor and as measure of
uncertainty quantification but
technically those two models don't need
to be in the same they can be separate
now i will focus on the second question
how can we leverage field knowledge
inside the circuit and this was
published at the end of last year on
archive
and indeed there is a lot of field
knowledge out there to leverage on for
surrogate models
we know a lot of pdes that governs
different physical processes in optics
thermal
quantum physics photovoltaics
climate modeling or mechanics
and so
uh coming back on our optics example we
want to fit so i'm uh looking at uh the
this uh uh
uh uh
box the the the the the
rank top left rectangle we want to fit
the complex transmission computed by an
accurate solver that is symbolized by a
picture of james clark maxwell
and the idea of the physics enhanced
deep surrogate the other box called pads
is to combine a neural network generator
with a low fidelity model here
symbolized by a cartoon of james maxwell
in itself the low fidelity model is very
inaccurate with an error of more than a
hundred percent uh but it contains uh
knowledge of the physics it contains
maxwell's equation
could contain you know in other
applications consideration laws
and it computes much faster than the
high fidelity solver
the surrogate model takes the same
geometry as the accurate solver and
inside pets there are two channels
one is a field knowledge based
transformation of the input to an input
of the low fidelity solver
and the other goes through a generative
neural network that will alter
this low fidelity solver input
trained end-to-end the neural network
generator finds the input to the low
fidelity model that will result in the
same complex transmission
as the computationally costly accurate
solver for maxwell's equation
this type of surrogate model
is about 10 000 times faster than
solving for the custom maxwell's
equation directly in 3d
and here i am presenting the fractional
error with respect to the number of
training data for these optics surrogate
uh and i compared the results of pets
combined with my active learning
algorithm which i presented before
and i compare it to this uh
the neural network only baseline and
also to an improved baseline that uses
active learning and and the the
improvement is really dramatic and
potentially asymptotically faster
looking back on the motivation for pairs
uh it can be applied to many different
physics problems
low fidelity model is very easy to find
it can be for example a model that is
reducing the resolution
um
it can be a model it's simplifying the
physics for example i don't know uh
removing a non-linear term
in the pte
and and you can apply this pad strategy
for many physics problems we're
currently looking into 3d maxwell
surrogates and surrogates for the
boltzmann transport equation
i wanted to um
talk about um
these projects are now uh both uh fully
implemented in julia uh the active
learning project uh
work currently and stan extended
extending this active learning algorithm
with
random uh and integrating it into
julia's sim circuit the jl and for the
physics enhanced deep circuit i'm going
to release the code soon
it's currently um
uh
not really uh open source ready um
but uh it was easily uh it was easy to
stack the neural network with this like
solver layer using
flux.gl and zygot.jl
and for the
propagation through the solver layer
under the hood what it's doing is on a
joint simulation that is
solved inside an r rule uh that was like
custom defined using chain rules.gl
and the code runs on cpu unfortunately
because um
it uses sparse solves which are not
supported on gpus
and solving for the low fidelity solver
in my case required as par solve
but i i did parallelize the batch loop
when training
the model
using mpi.jl
and they're all reduce function which
also needed
another our specific rr rule
i'm very excited uh to be presenting uh
here and invited to give this talk and i
am open to collaboration so please
contact me if you want to use this
framework for your own physical systems
and i will also uh yeah answer questions
and discord minutes uh
for for your talk but but uh but yeah we
can uh
let me quickly check the the the discord
um
yeah um
actually um maybe i should perhaps lead
with my own question um
so there's so you spoke about you know
that you're looking at a course geometry
and then you're you're using a
generative network to uh to generate the
fine geometry and how do you train that
generated network you use like a
multi-grid method to figure out like an
interpolation interpolating factor
between some course geometry and a fine
geometry and just keep training that
into
tree keep training that gant to imitate
that interpolation of how exactly do you
train it
yeah so
you know you have a lot of freedom uh uh
in your generator uh
in the slides i've showed it it's
actually um
uh using a the parameterization of the
fine geometry so it's you know it's
using those width of the different
rectangles uh
and then it's just a a fully connected
neural network that that uh
outputs like the
a corsified
uh version of the structure that will
you know result
in in the same
complex transmission
once you solve it with this low fidelity
solver and so matching the high fidelity
solver
but i'm also exploring uh
uh an in another project like uh
uh more of a converge convolutional arc
architecture when the input is just like
define image directly
um
and and right now it's it there's no
there's it's not like uh
adversarial uh
you know uh
type of approach it's just uh you you
have this you have this generator um
uh that's that
which output is used by your low
fidelity solver and then you're just
trying training end to end to match uh
uh the surrogate output that you need
well that makes sense thanks um this is
a question from youtube um you mentioned
earlier in the in the talk about drawing
candidate points at random yeah
so it was like uniformly uh at random oh
yeah so that that's like uh that's the
baseline we used yeah okay look the
question is is what distribution that is
and you and you just uh answered us yeah
yeah and then basically this active
learning uh algorithm is is really kind
of a bayesian algorithm where uh you
know you're
you're you're you're basically changing
the the the distribution of of uh of
your sample points
by using this filtering technique
um you also have a couple of questions
from discord so um
does peds introduce a new level of a
peakness in investigation of uh the
maxwell equations
uh what does it mean by by opaqueness uh
i would say if anything it's it's adding
knowledge and it's making it more
interpretable uh you can for example um
uh inspect what uh
what is the generated low fidelity
structure and uh maybe make sense out of
it um
so so in a sense of interpretability of
your model i think it's and and you and
then the low feed server is really just
like a solver for the pde so it's pretty
interpretable
okay but i might have misunderstood the
question
yeah i um
yeah i guess that's that's one
interpretation um there's there's
another one on discord and on youtube so
why do you need a a spa solver instead
of a lower resolution then solve you
know specifically
when when talking about the fddt
simulation
yeah so it's an
uh a frequency domain simulation so you
have you know uh your
your you you have your operator that is
you know matrix which is uh
uh you know uh very sparse so you want
to use this uh property in order to
you know solve it efficiently and be
able to scale a little bit
okay
and um i think the the person who asked
the question about the bigness
by a peakness they meant that uh you
know there is
there's an extra layer added right i
mean there's this generator layer added
that that perhaps uh is not
interpretable or perhaps is not um
we that we don't quite
may not know how to interpret as well uh
so have any comments on that yeah in in
the archive paper we actually have a
whole section about uh
uh uh you know physical insights uh
related to the the generator um
so you can see what it generates and
then uh we did also some
pca analysis of of the generator and we
could like
and and and and this all like the the
results we found like all made sense for
example
uh for
um
higher
frequency um
which corresponds to shorter wavelength
the generated structures like were
varying varying much more
compared to like low frequency
uh
type of gener
generations
okay so i think um
i've exhausted the questions from
youtube and slack but i had one i had
one more on uh on on geometries again
aren't there other aren't there other
types of methods out there that generate
uh geometries for you know for for pde
solutions
um and you know if so if is do you get a
chance to look at it any of the other
methods
so the the method i've
i'm not sure i'm answering the question
but um there is a whole literature on a
technique called space mapping um
and the major difference is in space
mapping the the
the dimension of the
uh the dimension of your low fidelity
solver is the same as the dimension of
your high fidelity solvers
you don't have that um
that freedom uh in the generation in the
generator you don't have as much freedom
uh
so but that's that's a very large
literature over the past 20 years um
yeah
all right that that makes sense there's
there's one more question on youtube
about benchmarks um when you said your
approach is faster than pd solvers you
know how how much faster
um when i approach what
um so supposing um you know let's say
you're solving the maxwell's equations
right oh yeah yeah versus yes so so in
order to get this complex transmission
so like it's a surrogate model it's not
a solver right so you you only care
about the complex transmission for
example for some other applications uh
in in thermal
you might uh care about the thermal
conductivity of your your structure uh
or like the young models in linear
elastic mechanics so there's just one
number um and so uh
to to compute that number uh it's uh for
as much uh go back in optics
it's uh ten thousand times faster to
evaluate that pads uh compared to
evaluating the brute force microsoft
all right that that makes a lot of sense
um
we have 15 minutes until the the next
stock but um i think uh
maybe we'll we'll close this talk and
just break for 15 minutes and come back
wow
thanks again rafael this is great i
really enjoyed it
[Music]
all right we are going to take a break
now and we will be back at
3
40 p.m uh est
all right welcome back everybody uh
we will we will start the next talk
very soon
um
let me try and
add the their
pre-recorded video here
um
right our next uh next speaker is
uh ching yuchu
um who will be talking about
fractional auto computing and modeling
with julia um
this is the pre-recorded video so
um once the video is make sure to ask
questions on the chat that uh ching you
can check out
either
uh you know whenever it's uh it's
morning for him so
um we would appreciate uh we would
appreciate you just directing the
questions to the chat
and let me just start it off
hello
everyone i'm going to introduce you how
can julia be used in fractional order
computing and modeling
well
we already studied classical calculus
we can get the derivative and integral
of a function
but you may wonder
is there a half derivative or equation
integral
the answer is yes we have fractional
calculus
so here
we have a simple introduction of
fractional calculus suppose we have a
function f x equals cos power of x
then we can get the first derivative and
the second derivative
we can extend
to the nth derivative
so here we replace
n to a half we can get the half
derivative of f x
so
you maybe wonder
we already have classical calculus what
is the meaning of fractional
so since the dimension of fractional
calculus it has shown its powerful
application in mathematics and
engineering
so i believe fractional order modelling
and computing will only become more and
more appealing
so first we will see the fractional
cochlear gl
is a package is the julia package
we can use to compute fractional
calculus
there are differences derivative and
integral in
fractional calculus so
we also have support for all these kinds
such as capital remaining
and animal sins
the usage of fractional cochlear gl is
very simple just call frag diff and frag
and pass the
function
order
the the specific point and this step
size and choose an algorithm to compute
the derivative and integral
so here is so here is the different
order of
different functions
so
with the help of symbolic utils.jl
we implement symbolic half-order
fractional differentiation and
integration
while these features are still in test
periods
i think i still think these features can
help researchers a lot
then we can see the fractional difficult
gl
here is the problems overview of all of
the problem types in fractional
difficulty l we have fod problem f pde
problem
fdde problem fie problem and many more
so we can start with the fbod problem
which is fractional ordinary
differential equations
we can divide f ode problem into
two classes first we will see the single
term as ote
which means there is only one
fractional differential equation there
is only one fractional differential
operator
in the equation
all we need to do
is
define the problem
like similar to differential equations
to gl by passing the function
order
initial condition and the time span
choose an
algorithm and with our
solutions we can see the solver achieve
a high precision
then
we can see the multi-term sode
there are many
fractional differential operators in the
in the equation
so we can
so we can abstract the mathematical
models and
define our problem by passing the
parameters
orders right hand
function and time span
choose an algorithm
then plot the
approximating solutions
so then we can see
the system of fractional differential
equations
it's very easy to solve the system of
fde
but here what i what what amazed me the
most must be the enhancement of
fde servers
so when you mess up
we
we are so you might have we are
we are solving a trial system
using ftfotf
toolbox
but it cost us
20 minutes to complete the simulation
then we use math then we use that before
then we
translate the code from matlab to julia
then we only cost eight minutes to
complete the simulation and
that is just what we
and that is
we just translate the code from matlab
to julie so i believe there will be
more improvement in fractional
difficulty
so here is some
fractional order chaotic systems
very beautiful
then we can see the fractional partial
differential equations
there are relatively little sources for
fpde
mainly focused on diffusion equations
and advection equations but i think
there will be more source in the future
then we can see the fractional delay
differential equations
it's also very easy to solve these
problems
abstract our mathematical models
similar to differential equations of gl
and
choose an algorithm and solve the
problem plus the numerical solution we
get the we got to get our solutions
then it's very easy to solve system of
ftd
just
define problem
solve problem and
solutions
then we can see the distributed order
differential equations
so what is the distributed order
the
the the differentiation order is no
longer integer all
fractions but the width function of
distribution of order
the mathematical definition is as
follows
similar with
similar with
what we had what we said before just
define our problem
by
let's say here is an example
define our problem with parameters here
we have the parameters of the orders
the
here the omega
alpha
is a function
and the right hand side through an
positive function
and
so here we
choose install truth and server to the
server to solve the problem and report
that we can put our solutions
then we can see the fractional integral
equations
well well the
well the fie problem is still in test
periods but
it's very it is very exciting
with the help of approximate gl
fractional difficult difficulty
fractional difficult gl is able to solve
fractional integral equations
like the example we have second kind of
integral equation
similar with
similarities before similar with what we
have what we said before
f
dde problem here we define our f i e
problem
with the parameters
orders
and right hand side
and choose a solver
plot our solutions
we get our
we get our approximating solutions
so then
we take left function
as the
queen function in fractional calculus
many
many solutions of
fractional differential equations are in
forms of
metabolic
function
in fractional difficulty gl
we have built in with tech level
function computing we support
one parameter two parameter and three
parameter metabolic for function
computing
so here here is the different order of
metagrapher function
yeah this is the
one parameter version
okay
i have to i have to admit there are
also some imperfects in
in these libraries
there are still more there are still a
lot of works
we need to do in the future
for example the design python
and the benchmarks
also the documents there are some
missing documents we need to
we need to fix so here inside ml
conference
i call for
developers
who interested in
fractional differential equations and
julian to join us so
our mission
our mission is to
make the fractional order modeling and
computing more easier
with julie
that's all thank you
all right thanks thanks for that uh
ching-yu we apologize for the the audio
issues here um you know while
while these audio issues are uh
undesirable at virtual conferences they
are just far too common
um
so um we we again we have time to spare
before our next talk so what we're gonna
do is take a break until
our next
talk which will start at 4 pm
um
right
see you see you guys in but don't forget
to ask ching you questions and in the
discord so that you can get to them
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
all right the music should have stopped
playing
um
all right uh gabriel i'll uh quickly
introduce you
and you could start at 4pm shop that
sounds good
uh you are mute by the way
can you hear me right now
i can hear you all right now and your
and your screen is visible too so that
sounds great all right
it's four so i'll introduce you um
um please let me welcome uh gabriel
bernbaum who's gonna talk to us about
modeling plasma physics with
neuralpds.gm
cool thank you so
hi everyone so my name is gabriel
bernbaum and i'm an independent
computational scientist based in san
francisco um during the day i actually
work at a tech startup here called
substack and at night i work on like
modeling differential physics which i
find quite neat as a little hobby
and today i want to talk to you about
how i used um neuro pde to solve some
plasma physics models and to build
plasma jl which is this interface to
make it easier for others to do the same
so we're going to talk about building
this interface extending neuropity to
these use cases and generally working
with physical physics and foreign neural
networks
so
first let's talk about what is a plasma
not to be confused with the blood plasma
or what we're talking about here is the
superheated matter also known as the
fourth state of matter so when something
is very cold it is in a solid state you
heat it up a bit it becomes a liquid you
heat it up more it becomes a gas and
when you heat up a gas
to a certain point um in really extreme
temperatures the electrons are basically
ripped away from the atoms making it an
ionized gas
which is also called a plasma and these
gases they're electrically conducting
systems and their behavior is pretty
complex
as you can see you know gas models are
already pretty complex to model
and once one adds electrodynamics to it
the system becomes even more um
intricate
but in any case plasma is pretty
important it comprises over 99 of the
visible universe stars or plasmas
nebulas or plasmas
and um it is the active goal of
part of astrophysics and much of nuclear
fusion research to predict
the behavior and movement of plasmas
so
i guess the question comes up that how
does one monoplasmas and one way to do
that is through the vlasov equation and
this loss of model is one of the most
accurate models that we have to model
plasma behavior it's a kinetic model and
it describes the time evolution of the
distribution function of a plasma
it is also one of the most complex
models that we we have in plasma physics
um as you can see here are um
a lot of math we don't need to worry too
much about it
gabriel are you are you uh are you
changing your slides there because we
cannot see the the slides changing
oh that is odd did you see this
uh no
um you see this now no i can see it's
changed let's do it like this then sorry
about that um
okay so we were here
what is the plasma and now we're talking
about
positive lots of equation sorry about
that moving along
so basically um
the
as i was saying the blast off equation
describes the time evolution of the
distribution function of plasmas
and it is a pretty complex model um i'm
not going to go into the
math here per se but as you can tell
here this is this is pretty complicated
it is um a phase-based model so it can
be up to six dimensions plus time um so
you need to know the position and
velocity of each particle um or um at
each point which is you know
a lot of dimensions it is also a
self-coupling system so here the
distribution function f
describes
and defines rho and j and rho and j
basically um define the electro electric
and magnetic fields e and b and these
fields then impact f so this makes the
system pretty non-linear
and that is like sort of a really par
hard makes the whole system fairly hard
to um model
as well and
because of that it is pretty hard to
solve this numerically and we still
don't have good models for it
um
and you know some other things make it
harder like the system needs to conserve
um charge and momentum and preserve
positivity of the distribution function
and it's hard for the meshes um
generally to handle several
characteristic speeds so you have waves
that are really fast and waves that are
really slow and they're interacting
together at all times um and that's
pretty hard to to figure out
um so we thought about just doing what
about physics and foreign neural
networks can we use that um instead of
meshes to to
solve this
and
we
thought that this was a good idea
because the initial approach is
basically like let's give it a shot
right
let's try this like new new new way of
modeling things
and see how far we get
and i think it's important to highlight
and i wonder what christopher cox would
say about it so i think this is sort of
one of those good use cases for physics
and foreign neural networks i think they
are overused but in a case where
something is high dimensional and our
numeric models are not very good and
circa models are quite attractive
then
using physics and formula networks could
um make sense
so
as
many of you might know uh
newer pde is the package in cyaml
that takes care of solving of you know
is the solver package for neural
networks in the simol ecosystem so i
turned my attention to it um to try to
build on top of it
and to build plasma models on top of it
um but there were a few problems at the
time so for one um the the
last half equation is a heterogeneous
integral differential equation with
indefinite integrals
and at the time neuropd did not support
integral differential equations nor do
they support heterogeneous systems nor
in order to support indefinite integrals
and i still wanted to do this so what i
did is i actually just went into the
code and started to like
contribute to it
i mentioned this fairly
um just because i think it's a good
model to contribute to simone this way
like trying to expand the scope of what
it can do and
thus like doing cool things with it um
and it was a lot of fun so i you know
encourage everyone to do the same
but
that's enough talking um how about we
talk we go through uh code example
and uh
we we just walked through it line by
line but i'll just basically describe it
first that um
plot plasma is basically
uh
an array of distribution functions and
species so you you give it
you give a plasma
you describe the plasma by saying hey i
want this plasma to be electrostatic or
collisionless and then you you define it
by setting up the distribu initial
distribution function and the initial
species that species has a mass and a
charge and with that knowledge we can
create a full plasma model that we can
then um pass to a solver to create a
simulation
so the first line here we just call
plasma and all its contents
the second and third line there we just
defined the temperature that's going to
be used to define the maxwellian um
distribution of uh of the the plasma
that we're trying to model
and then in line four and five we define
species these are predefined species
that are already um in plasma jl so this
is a deuterium ion and the other one is
an electron
um
then
the lines underneath that
we then set a distribution object based
on the maxwellian initial distribution
and the species d
and the same analogously to e
what we're doing here this maxwellian
distribution is already predefined in
platform.jl but you can also create your
own
distribution functions
we don't need to think about the
geometry right now but basically what we
get at the end is that we get to define
a plasma as an electrostatic plasma that
takes these distributions
and the geometry
and
this this object can then be passed to
the solver
that can then take in any kind of
you know can do any kind of dimensional
um
solve with any strategy available in
your pde
any number of layers and of neural
networks and that's all sort of like
abstracted away so you can you can
configure it if you want to but we have
like reasonable and sane defaults to
make it even easier to model plasmas
so
let's see what this
looks like this example this is a pretty
boring example because it's uh it's
plasma and equilibrium you barely see
any difference um as the code sort of
progresses but um
the good news and this is not just
displayed here is that this preserves
momentum and and and energy which is
like a good sign of a model that is
working in the plasma world so
um
moving along to another example which is
a little bit more
um complex is the two-string instability
which is a common benchmark in plasma
physics between codes like we we check
how accurate they are how fast they are
and so on um
and uh we'll just walk through this once
again line by line
so once again we call plasma
and then we define the species um
electrons
and now we're going to create our own
initial distribution function called two
stream er and each distribution function
in plasma jl
um
returns a function that has that needs
to have two arguments one x and one v
for the position and the velocity of the
particles those can be scalars or or
vectors
and basically
we create the initial condition of two
stream instability
we
pass that function or we call that
function here in the distribution and we
create an object here um d e with the
the
electron species so the distribution of
e
we call geometry let's ignore that for
now
and then we um once again call them
lecture static plasma and then we solve
it with a slightly different time span
slightly different time domain and space
domain
um
which seems pretty clear let me know if
you have questions there later
but um this
is a more interesting example as you can
see here let's see if we get this to run
okay so here we start to see some more
interesting behavior but also some more
problematic behavior
for one um there's an interesting thing
here
is that the neural network is capturing
the behavior but it's not capturing the
initial condition very well and you can
see that
slightly small here
but that the loss
struggles to converge and it's basically
dominated by the initial condition of
the distribution function f
so that means that um
and you can see that in
the simulation as well that this takes a
while for it to stabilize and form this
this like stream
um
and these are this is a problem that can
be mitigated now that we have domain
decomposition and adaptive loss
particularly adaptive loss
and neuropde thanks to zoe mccarthy's um
pull request that was
emerged a couple weeks ago so this is
definitely something that needs to be
improved upon um
in the future
so let's talk about the features of the
plasma jl interface i touched on this
briefly but basically the goal is to
model
any number any any plasma so easily
right so that means that we need to
model any number of species any number
of dimensions with any training method
with any distribution and either
electrostatic plasmas or collisionless
plasmas
just like super easily so we build the
interface so that you can create a
plasma object that takes an array of
distribution functions and each
distribution function has an initial
distribution and a species
and uh you can pass that to a solver
which returns a plasma solution which is
an object holding like
all elements that you need to like um
analyze the solution that you got
and you can sort of see us you know you
can sort of play around with this a
little bit in the sense that you can
create your own species or use a
pre-made one create several types of
initial distributions
as you can see here with the hot carrier
example which is a different plasma
benchmark
um
and then you can always
set a plasma to be collisionless or
electrostatic and then solve it in one
to three dimensions which is actually
three to
six dimensions plus time
um
yeah
so
just in conclusion
i know i talked fast sorry about that um
what was done is that we attempted to
solve the loss of maxwell on philosoph
plus on um systems with physics informed
neural networks we built support for
indefinite integral differential
equations and heterogeneous systems in
neuropde
we created a solver for plasmids based
on neuropde
and we open sourced plasma gl as an
interface to easily model these plasmas
of physics and foreign neural networks
and the future goals um and basically
our road to v1 is to add gpu support
these are pretty heavy models and i've
been running them in julia hub and like
the cheapest um cpu which is not ideal
and this needs to be fixed upstream um
probably in the nearer pde level
um
we want to add decomposed
domain decomposition for um
to increase accuracy and to increase um
the conservation of
mass and momentum and um
energy um in some of these models that
that i ran um conservation um started to
wane as the model advanced um with time
and with the domain decomposition we
think this is going to be well mitigated
um we also want to use depth of laws for
some some models that are harder to um
that you know that struggle to converge
like the one i i showed earlier
we want to create a makey recipe for
better graphing right now this is a
problem with neuropde as well and we
need to get a little bit better at
graphing i think this needs to be solved
a little bit further upstream
and then we want to add support for our
surrogate models in an interface
which is already possible on your pde
and then also add batteries included um
validation
um so basically
i can ask hey plasma jl how well is my
how good is my model and it can just
show me the conservation laws and how
well they're being
maintained in the simulation so i can
basically know how much you should rely
on
the model that i'm looking at
um
thank you um you can reach out on
discord or by email or check out my
github and i'm
happy to answer questions now
thanks gabriel that's very nice um
i
i'm just picking up some questions from
youtube and discord um
so
the first question is what is your plot
show for the two stream instability how
does this compare to
a kinetic or pick model
oh yeah so basically that one is i'm
basically
i get the question because i zoomed in
into one stream
over there so basically you you could
zoom out and then there are two streams
down there i just wanted to show the
weird behavior that you saw on on that
one stream on top but basically it's the
same it's it plots f versus v
um
in
zero to four
domain
um
and that's like
different from a particle in cell model
because you're not actually moving a
particle you're just seeing the solution
to the vlasov equation in that time
and space domain
all right
next question uh how does your model
handle kinetic effects like land
outdating
um
well the blast-off equation generally um
neglects some
some um landau damping um if i recall
correctly
definitely some scattering is neglected
there um
basically it's it
models everything it's supposed to model
everything the blastoff equation models
and it's supposed to neglect everything
that philosophication neglects right so
it's basically
just plugging in the lots of equation
and to a physics and formula network and
seeing what it does
all right um next is the number of
particles in each species defined by the
distributions you mentioned is that a
limit
um and as a follow-up is that also is
that also a way to add boundary
conditions
or external fields
um can you repeat the first question
the first question is uh is the number
of particles in each species i i assume
that this question is specific to a
slide uh yeah yeah
is it defined by any distributions that
you mentioned uh or is that a limit
yeah so
so this is a little dif so this is a
particle and cell method has like a
number of particles and
and what we're doing here is is really
just solving
mathematic like approximating the
blastoff equation with a neural network
so it's a bit it's something a bit
different
all right um
i okay so last question
um
last question so how how can you do
hybrid models with plasma or gl
that will be that would be the ideal
thing i think so
um using that to develop surrogate
models
would be
would be great so because we you have
this thing in class on physics called um
gyrokinetic
models which are pretty accurate but
super expensive
um and doing that with like a hybrid
model with that and plasma jl will
probably probably be the way to go um
long term for like high accuracy
it is not something that's been
implemented yet and
so
yeah
all right um i think we can do one last
one like did you did you happen to
comment on boundary conditions um you
know or oh yeah you can implement your
own boundary conditions as well so
just go into the pin you know yeah so
you can also pick them like um to be
there clef or um neumann as well or you
know for for the distribution function
they can be reflective or not um or
periodic um that's all implemented in
the interface
all right uh you you have more questions
i think in you on youtube as well as um
as well as discord so do uh do check
both those out um and thanks again
gabriel i'm just going to move on to the
the next speaker real quick
thank you
um
next we have
avik
uh
who's
um i
always your screen is your screen is a
bit
i you know
ah
oh now now it's better i was confused as
to what was happening there
um all right i will quickly introduce
avik pal uh from the julia lab and mit
who's going to talk about mixing and
pleasant explicit deep learning would
skip the eqs and infinite time
neurologies
yeah
so hey everyone i'm avik and i'm going
to be talking about uh mixing into
certain explicit deep learning with skip
decks so this is a work done at julie
lab in collaboration with alan littleman
and chris uh so we'll directly get into
uh what deep equilibrium networks are
so they're essentially a class of
implicit neural networks which are used
to model infinitely deep neural networks
so what that means essentially we have
an explicit neural network let's say f
of theta
and we just want to apply the same
function over the input x at an infinite
number of times it's essentially an
infinite composition
uh but that raises two questions how
would we actually back propagate through
an infinite composition
and how do we reasonably store those
intermediate solutions because there are
potentially an infinite number of them
uh
so
what happens when you actually
iteratively evaluate the same function
over over over and over again
so there can there be many possibilities
but let's say three of the most common
ones the first one would be it that the
solution just diverges
one case could be the solution keeps an
oscillating between multiple values and
the third one could be that it reaches a
steady state or an equilibrium
uh this this third case is what we are
mostly concerned about because that
would mean that if we evaluate a
function uh for n times
uh and we reach a constant value we do
not really need to evaluate the function
till infinity we have already reached a
steady state solution and it doesn't
really matter how many times we evaluate
it next
so this is where the deep equilibrium
model comes in
so
instead of just uh
defining a new explicit model we are
just saying that the output of this uh
equilibrium model must be the steady
solution of the steady state equation f
of theta
with an initial conditions zero and
parameters theta
now
because of implicit function theorem
what we can do is if we differentiate
the function it turns out that we in the
backward pass we just have to solve a
linear equation
so we do not really need to so like
store any of the intermediate values
this is good because
if you see the equation it just means
that we need one vjp which uh which we
get from the reversed murata dev so
packages like psi code or reverser for
kevistat and we can solve the linear
equation using any neutron krylov method
which is really fast
and again like we do not really need to
store any of the intermediate com
computations
uh now that we know what deep
equilibrium models are like why are we
actually interested in studying these
models
first thing is that the back propagation
doesn't really rely on intermediate
gradients
uh so which means that these models are
really memory efficient like you can
have a thousand iterations or a hundred
iterations the memory cost for the
backward pass is constant
second you can have you are able to
model dynamical systems more accurately
so you can impose stronger inductive
biases into those models
and in a lot of cases that would
actually accelerate uh your learning
because you have stronger priors
the last and uh the case that we are
mostly interested in is that these
models can automatically adapt their
depth to the input so for exit models
you have a fixed model and given any
input of any complexity you have you
have to do the same computation
but let's see you have two cases where
one is a simpler input and one is a more
complex input you want to have more
depth for the more complex input and
have shallower depth for the easier one
so a deep equilibrium network or even
neural odes would automatically adapt
its depth based on what the input is
however like uh as we saw for debuculiar
network network in the forward pass you
have to solve a steady state equation
which is not very cheap
so how do we accelerate that and that is
the question that motivates us to
develop this new framework called
schemtext
so
like we have very simple intuition the
initial condition that we give to the
solver is not very good it's just zero
which doesn't really make sense
can we have a better guess
so what we do is we have a small
explicit model let's call it gfi
and we tell the network to guess a good
initial
condition for our steady state solver
so
if the model is able to predict the
initial condition that's really close to
this actual steady state we'll have to
perform less iterations
so the idea is that over time like as we
are training the model and we are doing
it end to end so we are jointly learning
theta and phi the model would learn to
predict the steady state solution or at
least get so close to it that we have to
perform very few iterations so
we can think of it like a predictor
corrector approach so the neural network
gfi is the predictor and
then the steady state solver is just
performing a set of corrections
but now we have introduced a couple like
a few problems like do we now we have to
we have more hybrid parameters in the
form of gfi which is not ideal
in our experiments we just found that if
it's at gfi to be f of same same as f of
theta uh it just works for all the
problems
and as far as how do we train it
we have then we just minimize the l to
norm between the initial con between the
guessed initial condition and the final
solution from
the steady state solver and that's and
that's the essentially auxiliary lost
term
and we can enter and back propagate
through this
uh we also explore another idea so
as you can saw that introducing gfi
added some extra parameters and like
since our entire pitch is around like we
have low
low memory requirements it's uh not
ideal to have extra parameters
so can we actually get rid of that it
turns out if we
instead of using g of
phi if we minimize so if we perform one
iteration of f of theta and we say that
the first iteration needs to be at close
to the steady state
solution
so what this does would be this would
incentivize a model to learn a simpler
dynamics and turns out in most cases
even this outperforms the skip text and
we just call it skip tech version 2.
uh
now i'll just uh introduce the package
that we have been working on for this so
we call it fasttech and it's publicly
available on github
so what do you do to define a deep
equilibrium network you just pass an
initial model
and you just say what solver you're
going to use for now let's call this
discrete text always i'll discuss what
they are in the later slide
to define a skip deck you would just
have to pass an additional function
which is essentially modeling gfi
similarly for the regularized decks or
skeptics we do you just i don't pass gfi
so like with the simple api you can
actually
perform all these kinds of different uh
deep equilibrium networks and it already
implements all
the linear solving in the back end and
everything
now coming to infinite time near low
ease or as you call it continuous decks
so the models that we saw in the
previous slides were modeling discrete
dynamical system
but
like discrete dynamical system come with
its own set of problems so consider a
linear
dynamical system uh with u naught equals
to one we know that it will converge to
a steady state of zero if alpha if the
norm of alpha is less than one
but if you see that if you set alpha to
zero point nine you will see that every
step is like for it's just slowly slowly
going to convergence so in most real
world applications we
uh evaluating the function would be very
expensive so we do not want to make a
lot of
evaluations
similarly if alpha is minus 0.9 it just
this value just bank bonds over the
steady state
so
like we consider these shortcomings of
dynamicals like discrete dynamical
systems and what we could do is rewrite
the deck as a continuous dynamical
system so instead of
uh finding a steady state for f of theta
z minus z
uh we are taking that quantity and
saying that this is the rate of change
of c
uh for people who are familiar with
neural odes the right hand side like if
the right entire right hand side would
be modeled by let's say g of theta that
would exactly resemble a nero lode e
uh and now we are solving this uh
uh infinite time zero low to e with the
initial condition c now z naught and we
are solving it till time t equals to
infinity for a neural or d we would uh
stop at a lesser time let's say at t
equals to 1 or 2 or something like that
also note that
this formulation
just works out of the box with skeptics
because we would just have to change the
initial condition and we have made no
assumption on what the initial condition
is for modeling it as a continuous
dynamical system
again like we uh provide outsourced box
support for continuous text and fast
tech
so this was the example from the
previous slide uh so we have a discrete
text solver so instead of just passing a
discrete text solver you can just pass a
continuous stack solver and pass your
favorite ode solver so here we are using
d5
uh and in most of the other ode solvers
would just work out of box you could
even use a fixed timestamp solver
and it should just work
now uh coming to a few results
uh so what we see is that our models do
indeed converge much faster to the
steady state
so here is a toy problem we are just
fitting uh multiple points to a
polynomial
uh if you look at the left most you will
see that the solution actually wiggles a
lot before it actually converges to the
red line which is the ground truth
skip deck also like doesn't wiggle that
much but also takes some time to reach
the solution whereas skipped if we do
our regularized text uh reach the steady
state really fast and they do not
actually wiggle
uh coming to more realistic cases we uh
if we run it on mnist turns out we have
like 2x faster training and six x factor
predictions
uh so our model is actually able to uh
circumvent a lot of problems with
implicit models which involve like uh
dramatically slower training and very
slow prediction so
uh we get closer to
explicit models we are not
completely there yet but this is
definitely a progressive scene in the
correct direction
now coming to continuous models
uh for
cypher 10 we saw that if we use uh just
the vanilla deck or with like even
continuously and discreet like none of
them actually converge to a steady state
this doesn't affect training per se
however
uh
the
yeah however if we go for continuous
skip decks we do see that the models are
actually able to converge with the
reasonable depth so for these models we
had like a threshold of a maximum of 25
layers deep for convergence and
within that only the continuous
regularized models could ah converge
finally this is uh some of the plots so
as you can see
uh we
like most of the models have
like the similar accuracy even though
the continuous skip models are converged
faster uh to the steady state which also
means that during prediction and
training they are trained faster
and uh thank you that's all
right uh thanks avik um
i have one question from discord
so um
what are some good applications oops did
i
yeah there you are
um
your screen is not on the stream though
ah there it is
um so what are some good applications of
dequeues in general uh what types of
problems would be good candidates for
for dequeues
so right now i would say uh
we can use any of these implicit models
for
in place of let's say any standard
explicit model so image classification
segmentation like uh a lot of papers
have shown that we uh these models are
competitive with uh standard direct
resonance and everything for imp like
imagenet and cocoa and all those data
sets
uh some other applications would be if
you're trying to uh fit a system and you
know that like and you know certain
parameters of it so any dynamical system
you could uh try fitting those in as
well
so basically anything it's so right now
we are just constrained with the
a training time and like a lot of papers
are currently working on the same
direction
uh also uh if you consider robust models
so there have been certain papers
showing that these models might be
slightly more robust to adversarial
examples
than exclusive models
all right i
um i'm just uh looking for more
questions from the slack and youtube but
in the meantime i
i had a question um i mean you were
talking about dynamical systems and then
you and then you showed us this mnist
example and and in my mind i couldn't
quite compute the connection between
image classification and dynamical
system so uh could you comment on that
sure
yeah so i i would think of uh like
dequeues as like a general framework for
like just doing a mapping right so you
have a like n-dimensional real plane to
an n-dimensional real plane you're just
performing a mapping
uh
so yes that uh we are so this mapping is
being performed by a dynamical system
but
the input can really be anything and so
and because we were targeting like a
more machine learning
uh like traditional deep learning space
it made sense that we have like an image
classification problem where the input
is like a 10 dimensional input would be
the image and we are just transforming
that image into some latent uh space and
then just applying some form of like
classification head over that
i see that clarify
does thank you um
let me
let me check the uh
check the other platforms um
have you uh have you tried have you
tried it on dynamical systems then and
uh you know
what sort of benchmarks and results you
see
uh we haven't tried directly
these models on dynamical systems
however like we are using like we are we
have been developing models inspired by
uh this idea of like better initial
guesses for stiff
uh systems and
i i can say that we are getting at least
like around seven to eight x performance
gains there like even if we include
training times and everything
i see
all right
um i think that's
i i know we we have like
three to four more minutes i think we
we don't have any further questions in
the chat
so what i will do is i will take this
time to thank you and uh transition to
the next set of speakers and
and get that all set up for them
all right thanks again awake
all right
hey
see you and zach welcome hello thank you
so uh sorry zach could you could you
test your audio again i'm not sure i
heard you well hi could you hear me yeah
now now i can hear you okay
um do you so do you guys want to both
share your screens and i can put
whoever's screen on
uh
sure
great yeah zach's going to be sharing
first
okay
all
right
try full screen yeah
yeah and uh uh we have another three
minutes so um you know you can start
then theo when will will you be speaking
over zak slides or do you do you have a
separate screen to share that i should
switch to
um i will be speaking first for the
first two and then
i will have a separate screen share the
second half of the talk okay would you
would you mind testing that screen share
as well because we have the time yes let
me do it oh looks like i have to quit
google chrome and reopen it real quick
so
could we start early then
[Music]
ha he's back
okay does this
work yeah um yes zach you could continue
sharing your screen right and
yeah so
what what would happen is you know
whenever
um whenever this you know i i can just
switch to your screen okay okay cool
okay
okay
all right
yeah so yeah you could just keep so here
your first screen
yeah i'm just gonna i'm gonna put your
slides on and since we are one minute
i'm just gonna start introducing uh
both of you
and um and then you can take it away
right
um
all right thanks thanks everyone and um
welcome back we are with uh theo
diamandis and zac frangela um who will
be talking to us about uh speeding up a
backslash b with a randomized
preconditional.jl
um
whenever you guys are ready you guys can
can take it off
sure um yeah i guess we'll go ahead and
get started and thanks so much for
organizing uh organizing the first imel
con so hi everyone my name is theo i'm a
phd student at mit in the julia lab i'm
working with zach who's a phd student at
cornell and we're going to talk to you
all about how to speed up linear system
solves with randomizedpreconditioners.jl
so next slide
so essentially we're going to show you
this uh you know one easy trick that
your professors are not going to tell
you about
to get a very uh easy 5 to 10x speed up
on iterative solves of linear systems
and we're going to do this by
constructing a very particular
pre-conditioner which is actually going
to go through how to do this next
hi everyone i'm going to give you an
overview of our preconditioning
technique randomized nistrim
preconditioning which was a joint work
of joel tropp at caltech and my advisor
madeline udell
so our setting for today is uh we want
to solve large symmetric positive
definite linear systems possibly with uh
regularization
and by large we mean a direct solve is
not computationally feasible
the ideas can be extended to other
systems such as symmetric systems but
we're mainly going to focus on the spd
case today
so the standard large scale
solver for symmetric positive definite
matrices is the conjugate gradient
method
it's very scalable because it only
requires matrix vector products
and we know c g converges quickly when
the condition number of a is small or
equivalently the eigenvalues are
clustered unfortunately a lot of times
in practice this isn't the case so that
could make cg quite slow but to give a
nice visualization here
on the left we have a figure that shows
spectrum that are easy for cg like the
ideal case here first figure on the left
the spectrum is completely flat and the
condition numbers one
whereas on the right here we have
spectrum that are quite hard for cg like
this first one
both these figures on the right the spec
the condition number is quite large
um
especially in particular this one on the
right you see the spectrum a lot in
machine learning applications so if you
notice if you could just kind of flatten
the top spectrum here you could get a
very uh well-conditioned system and cg
would be fast and
the precondition we're going to talk
about today does this
so what is a preconditioner so
preconditioner something that you know
has basically has to satisfy two
properties uh you can easily apply its
inverse and you know it makes results in
a nice spectrum where the precondition
matrix well conditioned if you get that
you know cg will be
very uh fast to converge
so like what our approach is is that uh
we basically find like the best possible
preconditioner for a certain class but
instead of doing it forming it exactly
which would be quite slow we approximate
it in a fast and efficient manner
so the ideal preconditioner for our type
of problem would be uh if you wanted to
just flatten the top spectrum the ideal
thing would be to find where you know
uh the rank k but you need to go to the
flatten the spectrum sufficiently and
you would form this preconditioner here
p
um so p
is a very easy to invert and cheap to
apply so to invert it you would just
flip this ratio here
and you would just replace lambda k plus
mu i by lambda k plus mu i inverse and
what this does is this flattens the
spectrum associated with the dominant uh
k eigenspace of the matrix so it
flattens all those guys to lambda k plus
one plus mu so as a result uh the
preconditioned system the condition
number reduces from lambda one plus mu
to over lambda n plus mu to lambda k
plus one plus mu over lambda n plus mu
so this is a very uh significant
reduction when the spectrum decays so
that's uh very helpful
unfortunately that's not very practical
because computing a partial exact eigen
decomposition is expensive so instead we
do it approximately using what's known
as a nice trim sketch
so it's kind of the by definition it's
given by this
expression here which is a little bit
unintuitive at this point but uh we'll
give an explanation for where it comes
from
uh so we do not compute this though
using this like naive expression here
because with the pseudo inverse because
that'd be numerically unstable our
procedure instead uh returns the knights
from approximation as an approximate
eigen decomposition v hat lambda hat v
hat transposed
um and here omega is just a random test
matrix uh the common choice to use is a
standard normal gaussian matrix
and where does this come from so it
turns out the nicer approximation
although it has a kind of funny
expression solves this very intuitive
approximation problem
optimization problem all we're doing is
we're just finding the best
approximation to a and the column space
of a omega so that's where this comes
from
and so just to give you a little bit of
a theory for why this works so the nicer
approximation does very well gives you a
very good rank r approximation whenever
the spectrum decays quite quickly this
is a older bound from like tropidal all
2017 if you want to see a more refined
bound for the approximation area you
could check out uh frangella tropidal
2021
and you know in the case of regularized
systems uh we've showed that you know
under the right conditions we're
constructing the preconditioner the
condition numbers is less than 28 in
expectation so you get a very well
conditioned linear system so that's kind
of the theory behind it in the idea now
i'm going to turn it over to theo for
the details on the implementation
go ahead and switch the screen share
all right great um so the implementation
of this is going to be in randomized
preconditioners
preconditioners.jl
and you can construct the nice stream
sketch with only two lines of code so
one line of code to construct the sketch
and then another line of code
to build the preconditioner and
sometimes you may want to get a p
inverse as well and so this can be done
super easily
with
a nice room pre-conditioner inverse
so these pre-conditioners in particular
have very efficient methods for solvers
so we use multiple dispatch to implement
efficient left divides and multiplies
and so this is done because we store a
factored sketch of the preconditioner
and then you can essentially just use
one keyword argument to pass these to
your favorite iterative solvers so for
example krylov.jl is going to use p
inverse and
iterativesolvers.jl is going to use p um
so all you have to do is set the
preconditioner keyword argument in each
of these
so we talked primarily about the nice
room sketch here
however if you're moving beyond positive
semi-definite matrices we included a few
other sketches and randomized
preconditioners.jl
in particular um for symmetric matrices
there's the eigensketch um and you can
do most of the same things with the
eigensketch as you can with the nice
room sketch
however if you're looking at general
matrices we also have the randomized svd
and so one additional keyword argument
here is this queue which is essentially
a powering parameter
which
does a type of krylov method to
have a more accurate sketch
so these sketches also come with several
utilities one of which is fast
multiplication essentially leveraging
the fact that they're stored as their
factored forms
and then some tools for adaptive sketch
size selection so one parameter that you
saw show up through this presentation
was this r parameter which is the size
of the sketch
and a lot of times you don't know this a
priori you would only actually know it
exactly if you could compute the full
eigen decomposition and the whole point
of these methods is that you don't do
that but you can use these adaptive
techniques where you say double the
sketch size parameter until your
estimate of
the norm of the sketch
minus the original matrix is small
and so a few examples of this
uh here's one of ridge regression um
with a uh with about 4 000 features and
this is a data set from openml
the eigenvalues of the matrix that's
constructed are on the left you can see
that essentially the rank of the matrix
is approximately 2 000
and then you can also see mu which is
going to be the parameter of ridge
regression which we choose as one e
negative four
on the right is the convergence of
conjugate gradient with several sketch
size selections um so several sketch
size selections are
and one thing in particular that i want
to point out is essentially whatever
parameter you choose you always get a
speed up here and these sketches are
really fast to construct so it almost
never hurts you to do something like
this
however you can see that even if we
choose a relatively modest sketch size
so for instance r equals 100 we get
about a 3x speed up despite the fact
that the tree right here is about 2 000
so it's much greater than 100 and then
actually as you go to a sketch that
approximates the rank so once we get to
r equals 2000 uh we get convergence um
to
uh we get convergence here in um nine
iterations so it can get really really
fast as you actually approach the rank
and then back to the example that i
showed at the beginning of this
presentation um here's ridge regression
with 15 000 features
and this is solved with the nice trim
pre-conditioner in under five seconds on
a laptop the um pre-conditioner itself
takes about two seconds to construct so
you're getting a total system solve
about six seconds with the nice drum
pre-conditioner versus about 25 seconds
with no pre-conditioner in addition this
is a case where the diagonal
pre-conditioner works quite well however
a lot of times the diagonal
pre-conditioner doesn't work
particularly well
however the nice room pre-conditioner
can usually
almost always get you some type of speed
up so again it almost never hurts
so uh to go from here um i encourage you
to check out
randomizepreconditioners.jl which has
these methods and that's on github right
now it's being added to the julia
registry in a few days
also this does work with linear
solved.jl which is the cyaml in your
solved interface so again just with two
lines of code you can construct your
pre-conditioner and then just put it in
whatever solver you call from
linearsalt.jl
in addition uh check out zach's paper on
nice drum precondition conjugate
gradient method and then for more kind
of in the randomized numerical linear
algebra
world you can check out this martinson
trop survey
which is recent and quite good
so to conclude and just highlight a few
future directions that we're thinking
about
um with this package in particular one
of the things that we would like to do
is add additional test matrices so right
now we're using that standard gaussian
normal test matrix that zach mentioned
and uh this is great for dent systems
however for spar systems it a lot of
times destroys the sparsity pattern
however there are some other test
matrices that are more specifically
tailored for sparse systems and so we
hope to add those to the package pretty
soon
um on the more research side of things
general preconditioners for
non-symmetric systems is pretty much an
open research question so if this is
something that's interested to uh
interesting to you or would be useful to
you or you'd like to collaborate on this
please reach out to us and then of
course we would like to um
improve performance and robustness a bit
of this package and then also work on
applications so both zach and i come
from the optimization community and um
being able to solve linear systems fast
is kind of a core primitive that are
it's in a lot of optimization algorithms
and so uh finally here are the
references that were cited in this talk
and then thanks for your time if you
want to contact us here at both of our
emails
all right
thanks a lot zach and theo's is actually
pretty exciting work um
so there's there's one big question in
the chat is uh you know uh does this
work with sparse matrices you said
there's limited support and you need
better support so
what's missing
yeah i guess so it works um it's just
right now kind of when you take that
sketch of the sparse matrix um you're
taking the sketch with something that's
totally dense so it kind of destroys the
sparsity pattern um that might depending
on the application and depending on your
sketch size that might be totally fine
and it might not matter um however
sometimes of course like you would want
to retain as much of that sparse
structure as possible um and so for that
like i said we're trying to add some
other test matrices that allow you to
kind of pick from a
library of test matrices
whatever the best one for your
application might be and so that's
trading off things like accuracy
versus sparsity preservation and so on
computational time that type of thing
okay uh we
there's uh there's another question from
youtube does it um can it take a random
number generator state you know just
setting a random number generator state
to make this entire thing reproducible
oh uh yeah
there's no reason uh why it couldn't
okay
um
so um even even with the um
so
even with your sketching right you don't
you maybe you don't even need to
preserve sparsely in a sense right you
just need
um you just need a a sparse matrix
that's that's sort of easy to invert
according to your accordion sketching
standard right and it just needs to
perhaps have the same sparsely level um
or or even if it doesn't it it yeah
maybe maybe just the space same sparsity
level given given the the memory
requirements of the problem at hand uh
generally speaking
so um
so so yeah do you have any comments on
uh comments on that you don't need to i
guess you don't need to the fact that
you don't need to preserve sparsity
or
i don't know
maybe that's what you meant by prison of
sparsity
zach do you want to take that one or
julian sure sure i didn't know like uh
so
i guess uh our current precondition the
one we talked about right um because
you're taking the eigen decomposition
ultimately you're going to get something
that a
partial eigen decomposition you know we
output it as u
and like lambda hat so the u matrix is
dense so it's n by r so you know that's
not ideal you might want to do something
different but there's ways of
modifying the construction where like
you know
you could keep the thing to be uh sparse
but we didn't really focus on that uh
some of the matrices we were looking at
uh when we were initially working on
this project was uh were dense uh
matrices for machine learning like
kernel matrices or data matrices at the
rise in ridge regression so that was our
focus but there's some different things
you could do probably to
better optimize for sparsity
okay that's the that that's cool um
uh could you uh could you recap which uh
preconditioners you've benchmarked this
against uh
um i i saw a little chart there
so like uh if you look at the
uh
the if you look at the paper we compare
it to other randomized preconditioners
so like there's a for least squares
problem a common one is uh rocklin and
tigert
we also compared to another method of
known as an adaptive iterative hessian
sketch
and uh for uh kernel matrices we compare
it to uh random features preconditioning
um but for uh this presentation we just
compared to uh we just stuck to diagonal
preconditioning here that's what uh
that's the jacoby and the second plot
that theo shared
all right sounds good um
otherwise uh well thank you both for
your time i don't see any further well
actually there is there could be one
incoming question uh on the
on the discord
um so i'll just wait for a second for
that
um
because you have four minutes
um let's see don't see any other
questions on youtube so let's
let's look at discord
all right it's taking a while um
[Laughter]
it's it's the the person who has the
question uh said that they were gonna
take a while to type the question
so um so yeah i guess they're they're in
a race for time here but um
well now this this this is great work i
i i really enjoyed this um i can't wait
to try it out with my with my stuff you
know sparsely i think would be a big
thing for for a lot of people
um
you know just just mostly because you
know pd's and all of that you know yes
yeah you want to preserve that structure
for sure
yeah
um all right
and we're currently working on applying
this in some optimization context which
also a lot of times have have sparse
structure as well
yeah i bet
um
okay so i'm
okay so the question hasn't come in yet
so what i will do is uh i will request
both of you to get on the discord and
sort of help answer questions there um
because it's fascinating work so um
so and i'm sure people are pretty
enthusiastic uh to ask more questions um
so i'd request you to check out the
discord all right otherwise i to thank
you both and i will welcome the next
speaker
sounds good thank you thank you thanks a
lot
all right uh we have two more minutes
um
we have two more minutes so um
you know uh one minute
uh you know at 4 59 i will introduce you
and um and we can um and then you go you
can start at four at five uh
sharp
okay that sounds good to you
sounds good
yeah could you could you uh say
something else please uh just to test
your audio
i thought it was faint for a sec
uh can you hear me yeah yeah this this
is better all right it was fainted uh at
the beginning okay
yeah but the this is i believe the uh
final talk for the day
um actually you know what i may as well
uh announce this you know this is the
final talk of the day after which we
will send out a zoom link to the discord
where uh you know we can join for like
for you know an open format discussion
um
but but we will end the live stream
after this talk
um
you know after you know i guess thanking
all the speakers etc but um
but um but yeah you should you should be
on the discord to look out for that zoom
link
otherwise um i will
introduce our next and fi our final
speaker of the day um king hyun lee um
he's here to talk talk to us about
bifurcation-based machine learning of
dynamical systems
uh take it away whenever you're ready
okay hello everyone my name is gyong and
i'm a phd student at university of
bristol and my supervisors are david
barton and ludube branson and today i
will
talk about
bifurcation-based machine learning of
dynamical system
which is um
example of applying cyano packages
for system with bifurcations in
nonlinear dynamical systems
i will introduce some examples um from
experimental bifurcation analysis
uh to using experimental bifurcation
analysis to build the dynamical system
models
i'll first show you some example of
parameter dependent systems that
undergoes bifurcations
oh sorry
um yeah i i have problem with
i think i have problem with
um
videos in this slide
yeah
oh
i said if you
you pro did you upload a pdf or a google
slide up here
i uploaded my slide here
i see
oh yeah it's um
actually it was shown in
my colleague's
slide in the sundoor's slide
and link store links to it and i can i
can just uh and i can just send it to
the discord if that's that's easy uh but
but but you should continue with your
talk oh yeah i'll just continue with it
um it's um
um
self-excited system example of
self-esteem systems
like um
in airplanes at certain speeds
there could be some limit cycle
oscillations on airplane wings and it
can end up
of disasters so
usually researchers doesn't want those
kind of problems and
these are the first example that i
wanted to show was
this
the
it's called error elastic flutter and
the wing
flaps at certain wind speeds and
the another example that i wanted to
show on this uh second slide a second
video was a wilshimi which
um which
at certain speed of the
vehicle with wheels and it can lose like
its control ability or many many
maneuvering
ability so it's called as limit cycle
oscillations and self-excited systems
and this type of dynamical system
without an external excitation is often
called the self-excited system and it is
quite challenging to make a model that
can predict this phenomena accurately
and i'll show you some example that if
we use psi ml packages
packages then we can model these systems
quite
interestingly
and self-extracted systems are typically
modeled with odes with hulk bifurcation
and
we can understand half bifurcation
geometrically from this figure here
and at certain parameter value of mu
we call this a control parameter and
there
can be change of stability
changing of an equilibrium and the
branch of
limit cycle oscillation
is generated at this equilibrium and
self-excited vibrations that we
observe
that are shown in the pre
previous slides
are some stable limit cycles
somewhere over
in the upper branch over here and
there are some interesting
characteristics of systems with
bifurcations that we can use in modeling
which is like
um existence of an invert manifold which
i will explain
from the next slide
and
invariant manifolds are sub manifold of
state space that are preserved under the
flow and this is a very nice figure
explaining the invariant manifold
of the flows start
and
flows starting in this manifold stays in
this manifold and dynamics on this
manifold is called reduced dynamics and
menu reduce order modeling starts with
finding this manifold from the full
scale of the ease and system with hope
bifurcation has a
center manifold and for example damped
mechanical systems has um
some invariant manifold as well
and in this in this case and we can use
the
existence of the environmental and the
dimension of the environment manifold as
the domain knowledge of the modeling
and this is a general framework of
training parameter dependent ode models
using machine learning and first we
model the parameter dependent vector
field using scientific
models or
universal or personators like neural
networks or
we can use hybrid models
and
we need to also
model the observations for example we
can model this as a just simple
projection map or
also universal approximators
and after we make a model structure then
we have to transform the parameter
identify identification problem to an
optimization problem using data fitting
criteria such as mean square error and
i'll explain from the next slide how we
infuse the domain knowledge of the
invert manifold and the bifurcation to
our machine learning problems
yes so
basically
i do experiment uh
for a system with with bifurcations
which is called experimental bifurcation
analysis this is the um bifurcation
diagram
measured from
fluttery experiment which is a typical
subcritical huff bifurcation measurement
on these
red circles are the
measured unstable periodic solutions
which are stabilized using feedback
controllers
and these blue
blue circles are the
measured stable limit cycle oscillations
so
if we
draw this
uh
by bifurcation diagram then we can
um
plot this like this
typical subcritical health bifurcation
diagram and
and this
we know the
bifurcation structure of this
this
measured system on which is a dyna
reduced dynamic on the invariant
manifold and
the interesting thing of nonlinear
dynamical systems are we can
use coordinate transformations to
transform this
this
dynamic system to a topologically
equivalent dynamic systems and we can
we we usually use
these coordinate transformations to
derive some
simple type of
type of
ordinary differential equations which is
called normal forms and
these are the simplest uh pulling
usually a polynomial type of equations
that um reproduces this dynamics in a
simplest form
and we can use these those kind of
differential equations as on our
[Music]
basis model and i'll show you how we can
train this
system using the normal form
so
uh i'm sorry about the
um
this equations errors um i don't know
what happened but um anyway i'll just go
on the
equation i have used to reproduce the
dynamics uh shown in the last slide is
using the subcritical of normal form but
i added uh quintic terms to reproduce
the satellite bifurcations
to
to
make a
stable
limit cycle oscillations on the in the
on the upper branch so this is the basis
model i used to
make a topologically equivalent
um dynamic system and the advantage of
using normal phone like locations is
that the shape of the trajectory of the
lcos of this system on the normal foam
coordinates are lcos just very simple
lcos with a circle trajectory and
if we transform this to a polar
coordinates and it's
it shows that the
amplitude of the normal forms are just
simple fixed points and
we can decouple the speed of the
oscillations
with the amplitude equations and
using
this basis model we can design the
bifurcation diagram very easily
using um
these are model parameters on a2 to
design
the um
design the bifurcation diagram and this
m this mu zero is the hoof bifurcation
point and
this large omega
is
to
model the speed of the oscillation
and i use neural network in my
in my
modeling case
and
this is the summary of training
on the
the um
observable um which is uh
basically according to transformation
between the
their manifold which is a center
manifold in this case uh between the
environmentfold and the measured uh
measured trajectory so
basically uh this
observable which is a neural network of
each uh it's a combination of linear
transformation and the neural network
transforms the
circle which is the trajectory of the
normal form and this two
measured um some complicated close form
shapes and
so
in order to match
this uh
transformed um trajectory to the map to
the measured trajectory i used uh the
metric uh between the
two distinct curves which i use these um
inferior coefficients of the closed
curve because a closed curve is a two pi
periodic uh
function on the polar coordinates so
i
measure the distance between these two
curves which i have
used as a loss function in the
optimization process
and
to summarize the
procedure of training the model i first
create the topologically equivalent
dynamic system on the normal form
coordinates which is
just
arbitrary coordinates
then train the this arbitrary
coordinates between
arbitrary coordinates and the measured
coordinates which is um observable
then
um train
the
um
another part of the normal form which
is responsible for the
speed of the oscillation which is
this omega function here
this is
um
the experiment that i
did in the wind tunnel this is the
flutter rig and
um
this
this system oscillates at certain wind
speeds and
i
measured this uh flutter phenomena with
this kind of rig and stabilized the
unstable periodic solutions using this
shaker
with a feedback control
so
this is the measured
bifurcation diagram these are the
measured uh
bifurcation
limits actual oscillations um stable
limit cycles in the upper branch and the
unstable limit cycles in the
in this lower branch and
we can see that the
bifurcation diagram
is quite accurately predicted and also
um we can
predict the
phase trajectory
of the
limit cycle oscillations
and
so
i also train the speed of the
oscillations using
the
optimization
which i used loss function to minimize
the
mean square error using difficulty
flux.jdl
so
you can see that
the speed of the oscillations are
very accurately pre
accurately trained
on the stable branch and as well as
unstable branch um the trick of
a little trick to train unstable branch
was if
because of the
unstable
unstable predict solutions for half
bifurcation is unstable direction of
the this
periodic solution is
on the
reduced direction
and
the
radius of the the amplitude of the
oscillation is the fixed point so i only
uh
did the time integration in the
tangential directions which is a
trivial flip fl with corresponds to
trivial
clock multiplier so i
didn't
have any problem with the um
stability issues in this case
i need to go faster and i'll show you
another example of using inver manifold
and
this bifurcation theory in training or
for system
with a
mechanical system with the harmonically
forced systems this type of
a system
has also invariant manifold which we can
understand as a non-linear version of
modal subspaces
so
these forced systems
also have bifurcation diagrams which
which is called frequency response
functions and
if we fix this uh force amplitude then
we can have one of the um this frequency
responses plotted here and
so
this system is actually a two-parameter
bifurcation problem with um which
like three parameters are forcing
amplitude and the
forcing frequency and
this red curve in the middle is called
the background curve which characterizes
the nonlinear um resonances
so this equation here is a
normal form of forced mechanical system
in polar coordinates
this row
is a amplitude of the vibration and this
on this side here is the um
is the
phase difference between the force and
the response and if we measure the
phase of the response and as well as the
phase of the
force then we can train
um
this normal form using the input output
map generated from
this this equation here
and in this case the steady state
responses have
very nice input output
map relations in this case um
rather than using numerical integration
in much training the machine learnt
model i used uh kernel rich regression
with uh
which i used kernel functions.jl and
to
optimize the hyperparameters here
so from the bifurcation diagram i have
trained the this machine learned model
to predict
the steady state response of the system
within their manifold and this is the um
experimental example here which i
uh which is just called a nonlinear
electromagnetic system and
i excited uh the
the base structure here uh using the
shaker
oh no i actually i didn't excited um my
colleagues i did this and i used the
data of this measure
this experiment to build the model
and
this is
this this this these curves are
bifurcation diagram
with fixing forcing frequency and
varying
forcing amplitude these curves are
called s-curves here and
these blue
blue dots here are used to train the
model
uh no green dots here are these these
green dots here are
the training data sets and using the
normal 4 model i train the machine
learning model and you can see here that
this
these blue blue circles here these are
the untrained
measurements and you can see that um the
model can predict the untrained
bifurcation diagram quite accurately and
from the backbone curve here measured
background curve here
we can see that the machine learnt model
can
extrapolate as well as the interpolated
leg um here
yeah
yeah i used um
julius aml packages to build the
parameter depended on the mildews from
data
and
machine learning modeling approach
developed here uses
environment manifold and bifurcation
structure as a domain knowledge and
for the future work i want i'm
trying to identify by invert manifold
from delay embedding maps and discover
um here i only discovered the tangential
dynamics of the invariant manifold but i
want to discover the trans transverse
dynamics of the environment manifold
which i can build a
much
much general dynamical system model
all right um thank you very much
right sorry um sorry i had to
cut you off this point it's a great talk
it really i really enjoyed uh you know
looking at all the experiments that you
generated data from um
but uh i uh we do have to move on to the
last item of the day um
and i'll have to give a few
announcements so i want to thank the
speaker once again
um
and then make a few uh announcements
thanks kyung
yeah thank you
so um thank you for uh bearing with us
or uh being with us until the end of
cymalcon um
we have one last item for the day which
is an open discussion the open
discussion will be on zoom and we are
pasting a zoom link
as of
right now
into the discord right so if you want if
you'd like to join this open discussion
please do join the zoom link on the
discord otherwise
um
you know chris unless you have any
anything further to say i i just want to
thank all the speakers
and uh and the keynote speaker let me
add you to the stream yeah yeah well i
just want to say
yes uh
thank you everyone um you know this was
a this ended up being a great conference
um we saw a whole lot of variety a whole
lot of applications a whole lot of new
methods
um and so
i i think that um you know i i think
that this shows that we should be doing
this again um when we came into this we
didn't know you know we have enough
applications like is our community large
enough um we have seen that we we've
gotten to the level of of being able to
to pull off a conference and that's uh
really exciting um there are a long ways
that we have to go we're still a fairly
small community
and
you know we're still a fairly small
community and um you know there's a lot
that we should be doing right to be able
to grow this community um and in you
know increase it in many different ways
you know in terms of contributors and
users and and everything um and so we'll
be launching a bunch of summer programs
in order to continue growing uh this
community and um i hope to see you and
chat with you about all sorts of things
you know technical and also just
community related in this um in this in
this uh discourse so you know if you
want to chat uh please join the the
discord um you will you know you'll see
our chats and then you can join our zoom
our zoom call and we'll be talking in
breakout rooms for the rest of the day
so thank you very much everyone
thank you everyone i'm ending the live
stream now